Oh,
okay.
We're live Remy Warren.
How are you fella?
Pretty good.
How's it going on?
I watched your show last night.
Oh,
did you?
I know,
I watched it again today.
The show's called Apex Predator.
It's on Thursday nights on the sportsmans channel.
Yup.
8:00 PM and they're getting,
this is a show that last time he came in with Dan Dodi,
we kind of talked about it off the record,
right?
We couldn't talk about it yet in the wind there.
It was not,
we didn't have any network for it yet.
We filmed the pilot episode and now it's,
it's a real deal now on television.
It's a real show.
It's cool and stuff like that happens.
You're planted out your work and it actually comes together and you have a real
television show.
It's pretty exciting.
So I've been,
I've been pretty pumped about it because this is something that I've been
thinking about for years.
And then,
you know,
we came in and was quite a while ago,
over a year ago or something like that.
Yeah.
And now it's finally come to fruition and people can look at what I've been
talking about for the last couple of years.
It takes a long time to make something fucking happened,
man.
It's this hurry up and wait game buddy.
Uh,
my buddy was in the army and he's like,
yeah,
wars.
Just hurry up and wait.
And it's like,
that's television.
Wow,
that's a jaded individual.
He done,
come on.
Can we just get to kill?
And folks,
um,
the show is,
uh,
what you're doing on the show is you're essentially emulating a lot of tactics
that various predators use and you are using these tactics to get clothes and
figure out how to hunt animals.
The one I saw last night was the buffalo one oh sweet.
Where you put a coyote outfit on and we're crawling up to these buffalo and it's
kind of fascinating that they don't run necessarily from coyotes or wolves that
just sort of walked towards them.
The only time the coyotes are the wolves would actually attack them is if they
were running that,
that's when they would move in on them.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because the way,
the way wolves hunt is they have to get the animals running first and tomorrow
night's episode.
We really see that when we look at the way wolves hunt,
but the reason that the wolf has to get the buffalo running is the wolf's
essentially outclassed by the bison.
It's so much larger.
So for the bisons say we're going to stand here and fight,
then it can kill the wolf and it's,
it's the cost benefit analysis for the wolf to attack that bison while it's
standing there isn't great enough.
So the wolves will actually get around the bison and try to instigate them to
run because if the bison makes the mistake of running,
then they can hunt as a pack.
They can wear it down once they get it moving and then they attack from the back
and they're safer and they're more successful.
So the bison know this,
so if they run,
whether they're going to be in trouble,
but when a human hunter comes along using primitive weapons or whatever,
the human hunter needs that animal to stand still in order to kill it.
So in the bice and sees a human it because that's how
it,
it stays safe.
So,
you know,
the point of this show is really dissecting the way nature does things and you
look at like every animal,
so specialized,
it does something really well and everything falls into a certain niche.
And as a human looking at nature,
we look at and go,
man,
what can we learn?
Like humans are an amazing species.
And what I've come to realize is we've adapted a lot of the techniques and
tactics that a certain animal specializes in or does really well and use it for
ourselves to become this,
this essential top predator.
So,
you know,
looking at this,
the plains Indians,
we looked at,
uh,
George Catlin painting where it's pretty famous painting.
There's plains Indians
painting Jamie.
It's,
it's a really famous fanning.
It's really cool
if y'all like that.
Yeah.
There's two plains Indians sneaking up on a herd of bison underneath these white
wolf skins.
And I'd seen that,
you know,
I've always thought that it was an awesome picture.
How do you spell his name?
George Catlin.
Ca,
I,
T,
l,
I n and uh,
yeah.
So you know,
he,
he paints this picture of what supposedly what he saw.
But you never really know these artists that shapes a,
this is from the 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
I mean this is pretty old photo.
So painting,
it was kind of a gamble whether or not he was kind of,
he was kind of going out west and painting what he saw or what he interpreted to
see.
And so I've always thought,
oh,
I wonder if that's really true,
but when you dissect it,
obviously those,
those plains Indian sitting around saw that,
Huh,
when those wolves are there,
those bison aren't running well,
let's throw some of those skins on her back and see what happens.
And it is a tech and like through the show we develop,
find out that text,
that top left corner there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Pull that sucker up.
Wow.
That's crazy that they really did that.
Yeah.
They must have.
And I mean,
it makes perfect sense if you're sitting there and,
and see the correlation between the wolves and the bison and you come to this
logical conclusion that if we act like a wolf,
the bison will stay there.
And I did worse than they were back then to a million.
And that's on that episode.
Steve,
you know,
he's the bice and expert and uh,
just how many bison were that he was telling me that they used to find the bison
by giant clouds from their breath.
It make like huge clouds.
What,
that's what Steve was telling me.
Wow.
I mean,
millions,
millions advice.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
there's a guy named Dan Flores that's a good friend of Steve's as well and uh,
he is a,
a real bias and expert and he's written a very controversial paper on,
uh,
what happened to the Bison and what he's saying is that he compares,
he's going to be on the podcast soon,
as soon as he's done with his book,
uh,
hopefully by sometime in the summer.
Um,
and what his,
what his paper is basically saying is that they were the plains Indians.
Once they had figured out how to ride horses and shoot from horses were already
on the way to wiping out the buffalo.
And the reason why the buffalo were in such high numbers was because that so
many people,
so many native Americans had died from smallpox.
And if you go back before the smallpox epidemic,
the people that had arrived in uh,
North America,
like the Dutch,
when they had made an accounting of all the different animals,
they had talked about turkeys and deer and elk and bear now,
no mention whatsoever of Buffalo.
And they were visiting all these same areas that 200 years later had millions of
Buffalo.
But during that 200 years,
90% of the native Americans had been wiped out by smallpox really.
And during that,
and then they were apparently like probably the number one Predator of these
bison.
I'm probably doing a really shitty job of explaining this.
That makes sense.
Do things like the buffalo jumps where it just drive herds of bison off a cliff
cliffs and they apparently the wolves with feed and cause they're just be dead.
I mean you couldn't take all that meat.
It doesn't matter if you've got a small village,
you're taking what you can use.
There'd be dead bison everywhere and the wolves would come in and gorge on them.
I guess there was an account where there was wolves,
so full on food.
They've usually just laying there in excess just
wow.
Gorgeous.
And they were just hanging around next to the native Americans.
Well where the buffalo jumped off cliffs.
They're native Americans were down there too with the wolves.
No,
I think I,
I don't know if they would move on,
you know,
certain point.
The meat's going to go bad.
Just keep eating.
Those are just keep eating and eating and eating.
Fuck.
Cause apparently a wolf's can,
they can gorge like a hungry,
like a wolf that's really hungry to read.
The red was on.
Yeah,
because they'll eat,
uh,
I read something that was like 20,
25 pounds in a sitting and they can process that meat in two hours.
So they'll just eat and eat and eat
25 pounds of meat processing.
Imagine if you ate a 25 pound Turkey,
like you went to the supermarket and pick up a 25 pound Turkey and you ate it
yourself.
And there's never been a wolf bigger than a human being.
Right.
The biggest wolf ever.
It's probably like 200 pounds,
right?
Yeah.
So we're talking about,
you know,
150 pound wolf,
which is the size of a normal man can eat 25 fucking pounds and go through it in
two hours.
That's insane.
Crazy.
Competitive eating at its finest.
Well,
their bite powers also freaky.
I didn't know Ricky Gervais' told me and I was like,
this guy has got to be wrong.
He said that a,
a wolf has a bite that's five times more powerful than a pit bull.
I'm like,
how could that be true?
Oh yeah,
it's true.
I can't fucking believe it,
but it's true.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
they're not that you look at like pimples all these muscles in their heads and
they're known for their bite.
Nothing compared to a wolf wolf can go right through an elk shinbone it's crazy.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I,
that's,
that's one of the inspiration.
Wolves are actually the inspiration for me
to even think of the show.
Uh,
I just,
I'm,
I'm pretty fascinated by woes.
But one day I was out hunting elk in kind of in Montana and I been hunting this
one bull and it was a first time I ever saw a wolf in the wild and it was
probably really close to,
I was like,
well,
this is awesome because this is before you really saw a lot of wolves.
And then I do,
I actually got a little video of it and then I go and do my hunt.
And then the wolf happened to be chasing these st hunting,
the same group of elk and a lone wolf.
Yeah,
it was by itself.
And I was actually telling,
I did Steve's podcast with Steve Rinella the other day and I was telling him
this similar,
this same story.
And every,
I've seen four times I've seen wolves take down an elk in the wild.
They've all been by themselves.
I've never seen a pack attack.
Oh,
I've only seen lone wolves.
Dad has gotta be amazing to watch that.
So it's cool.
I mean,
wow,
they're so fat.
You see like the,
you see the elk running and it's almost like the wolf is g it can like,
it could almost run between its legs back.
It's going back and forth.
The elk is bee lining and that wove his back and forth thing cause much faster.
Much faster.
Yeah.
So how do they take it out?
They bite its back legs.
Yep.
Grab Hamstring,
bite us back.
Like anywhere it can sink its teeth in but mostly go for the back end.
Do they try to take it down all in one shot or did he try to wound it and then
eventually get it?
I think it's whatever they can grab and half the time it ends up wounding it.
When I've seen him be the most successful is they run the elk into dead fall
because the wolf can go under and over.
The logs up and down,
back and forth and the elk struggles,
it uses all its energy.
It kind of gets trapped.
Um,
wow.
So the wolves kind of funnel them into areas where they know there'll be more
successful.
Like it seems like I've always seen him catch him on the downhill,
like run them down a canyon in the bottom of a canyon.
Seems to be where I'm trying to think about it.
Yeah,
it's like in the bottom of a canyon where there's lots of law and things down.
That's gotta be an amazing thing to see happen live because it's so rare to be
able to be there.
I mean,
you might see a wolf,
you might see an elk,
but to see a wolf kill an elk,
like to be at that moment where you didn't matter if you were there or not,
that was going to go down.
I mean that's a nature.
Exactly.
We were,
I was blood trailing my,
my friend's wife's,
she shot a nice bowl with her bow last year and we're sitting in there trying to
find this elk and here comes a cow elk running with a wolf hot on its tail.
And I was like,
sweet,
we're going to watch it go down.
And my buddy like yells at,
he didn't know what to,
I mean it was right in our face.
It was like right there and he just kind of yells and it spooks the wolf off and
I was like,
why'd you do that?
He's like,
he just,
he didn't even,
he's like,
I don't know.
I was like,
no,
he's just going to go on more.
I mean,
it would've been cool to at least see it.
You know,
you would have seen it,
right?
Oh,
we were 75 yards.
I mean it was right there in the open,
like in this burn.
It was amazing.
They're incredible.
I have so mixed feelings on wolves.
I mean,
one thing,
one part of me thinks they're amazing.
I love them.
They're fascinating.
But another part of me is like this reintroduction of them into the United
States.
It just,
I just don't think it was really planned out very well.
And their numbers are staggering now.
Oh yeah,
it's,
well,
when we talk about the American model of conservation eat,
there's checks and balances and goes with game animals and non game animals.
So when you reintroduce an animal into an area that it hasn't maybe never been
in that area or it's been so long that it's been in there,
they have to be managed as well.
Otherwise,
the whole ecosystem comes out of balance.
Well,
I watched this video about Yellowstone,
about wolves in Yellowstone.
It was talking about the impact that wolves have had in Yellowstone and all
these other animals that are thriving because of the introduction of the wolves,
and it's kind of interesting.
It's kind of interesting,
but the reality of those animals is their predators.
You're not talking about any other kind of animal.
You're talking about a predator.
It's like if you have a large amount of elk in an area,
a large amount of deer,
I mean this is a completely different animal than having a large amount of
wolves.
And when you're managing these types of animals with emotions rather than
objective logic,
that's when things get weird because you've got a lot of people,
their version of conservation never would include hunting a wolf,
but if you get thousands and thousands of wolves in a state like you,
you have to hunt them because then they start attacking livestock.
Like where I was up in BC where I shot that Moose,
there was um,
the guy that I hunted with,
his neighbor had a cow get taken out by wolves in the middle of the winter.
It's like cold and there was nothing,
not much for them to eat.
And I said,
fuck it,
let's just do this.
And they took out a cow.
You imagine like you're in your house and you're,
you're hearing,
you're looking out and there's 20 wolves just ripping apart.
One of your cow was like,
fuck man.
Yeah.
Once they figure out what an easy meal is too,
I think it's hard for them to go back to chasing Moose and yeah.
Other animals,
well they have no limit on the amount of wolves he can shoot up there.
You can shoot as many as you want.
Oh,
I don't think they could ever hurt the population.
What's so dense when you go up there,
everybody who lives in the city,
you owe it to yourself at some point in your life to go out into actual real
wilderness because there's all these people that have these opinions on animals
that are completely based on some Narnia,
like idea of what nature's like,
like they've never actually been out there like in real wilderness days,
in packing go days in where
you go,
Oh God damn.
Like I just,
I didn't get it.
I did just,
I just didn't know.
It's nuts out there.
I think the other,
the other assumption is people think that the real wild is what they would see
in a national park.
It's the zoo version of what wild is.
When you go out and do a place like DC or outside of any kind of park like that,
it's a completely different world and yet you don't see as many animals.
It's tough life out there.
Even,
I mean,
not that the boundary of the park makes it more animals,
but it's set up.
Those animals are climatized to seeing humans.
They don't have their same natural senses.
So if you go out and do a place that they aren't a climatized to seeing humans,
it's a tough go.
It's,
it's not as easy as people think.
Well,
it's not only not easy.
There's a weird silence to it out there.
I was like,
uh,
there's an eerie indifference that you get.
That's one of the things that we,
uh,
we went to a Prince of Wales,
Steve Rinella took us up there hunting a deer.
We struck out.
But it's,
it's an amazingly remote place.
Like you don't see it.
You know,
we didn't see a single fucking person other than us the entire time we were
there.
And you just,
it doesn't give a fuck about,
you know,
if you fall and break your leg and die there.
So what,
just so worth it.
You're just a part of this whole thing where everything is going to go.
There's bears there,
there's deer there,
there's all sorts of interesting wildlife.
But it doesn't give a fuck about you.
It's,
I don't think people kind of understand that.
And a real,
like an a in it will you really rationalize it or really like got it into your
brain?
Like this is reality.
And until you actually go into the woods to the real woods,
not yellow stone,
not central park.
The real woods are a different animal.
It is.
And that's when you kind of understand if you've,
if you've even,
I haven't encountered wolves in the wild.
I've seen what they've done.
We talked about in the last podcast,
I took some photos of this.
I'm a moose calf that we had come upon that had been killed probably like the
night before.
It was kind of interesting,
but,
um,
I haven't encountered them in real life,
but the people that I know that have,
have a completely different opinion than the people that live in cities that
think that you'd have to be an asshole to shoot a wolf.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're aren't around it,
it's so far removed.
I mean you cannot,
oh,
you almost can't even make an accurate assumption of what it's like.
No.
You also can't make an accurate assumption that you'd have to be a person that
hates animals to shoot the wolf.
That's,
that's the,
the management aspect of,
of wildlife,
especially when it comes to predators.
This is lost on a lot of people,
and it's one of the reasons why California doesn't have mountain lions seasons,
but like mountain lion attacks and California steadily gone
up mount lines.
Sightings have steadily gone up and they're kind of playing with fire because
there's like,
there's a lot of them here now.
They don't get hunted.
You know,
that's what I wonder what,
what the future's gonna look like in a place,
in the long feature.
Because in mountain lions,
if you look at African cats,
they're very dangerous animal.
But mountain lions or,
or I a shire version of the species,
and I think it's because they've,
they're in the predatory realm.
They weren't always,
they weren't at the top.
There was in California,
you look at California,
there used to be grizzly bears or,
or some sort of species of brown,
you know,
coastal grizzly bear and then humans hunting.
And so you had mountain lions that had to be afraid of things.
Now they're in a world where they don't have any predators and nothing's chasing
them.
At what point,
I mean,
maybe it's a hundred years down the road,
maybe it's a thousand years down the road.
At what point do they essentially become a different temperament of cat?
Much similar to the ones in Africa where they have to,
or South America or South America.
Yeah.
Where they don't have predators.
That's a good point.
You've got to keep those bitches scared.
This a family that we went to the farm to hunt Turkeys,
uh,
two weeks ago and uh,
they lost all their sheep.
Every single one of them in northern California.
All of them really allows all of 'em to mountain lions.
Hmm.
They're like,
they have so many cats up there.
They see them like in the day just hanging it out and like,
fuck man,
I didn't have an accurate account of how many they have.
Oh No.
It's pretty rare to see.
And when you,
if you start seeing them outline in the daytime then there's a lot of mountain
lines or are you just got super lucky?
Yeah,
I saw one in Montecito,
which is like a rich suburb of Santa Barbara.
I was driving down like a residential road and I saw this thing bounced in front
of the road and I thought it was a coyote at first until I saw its tail and
Whoa,
that's a fucking mountain line.
And in this like suburban neighborhood,
it just looking for a good restaurant to get a steak or a good dog,
good dog that it catches slipping.
Yeah,
I think I got,
I must,
my place in Montana,
I think I have some kind of strange mountain line breeding program going on
because every year at the same time it was just lying tracks all at or near the
cabin all over the place.
And that started to right when I,
uh,
the year I first came here and talked with you and it's just been continuing and
I don't know what it is,
but a friend of mine started chasing lines around there.
He said you would be surprised how many cats living in this area within these
six or seven within a few,
a mile or two.
It's crazy to hone ranch,
which is about an hour plus from here.
There's a great hunting spot.
They have pigs and rocky mountain elk and they have one trail camera on this
pond and they found 16
different mountain lines on this trail camera.
That's pretty crazy.
It's a huge ranch is the biggest ranch in California.
It's 270,000 acres.
And they have um,
just a,
a large supply of wild pigs.
Wild pigs are all over the place.
That's like their bread and butter for their hunting program.
Yeah.
When we went there we saw feel like we only last time I went,
I went like real recently,
um,
we were bow hunting.
We saw 50 pigs.
Yeah.
And we didn't even see a lot,
a lot at the time before that we were seeing hundreds of them,
just hundreds of pigs all over the place.
Did you end up getting one first time?
Yes.
Second time.
Now that's cool.
But it's pretty good.
Yeah,
it's delicious.
It's very different.
It's very different than um,
like I had wild Turkey and I was surprised at how much it tastes like Turkey,
you know,
especially the breast.
I was like,
it's good,
but it's Turkey,
Turkey,
but you eat wild pork and you're like,
Ooh,
this has got a different thing going on.
It depends on the,
the pig,
the pig you get because if you buy pork,
if you shoot a bore,
it tastes a lot different than a sour or even like pregnant sound maybe.
But I,
uh,
in New Zealand we get quite a few pigs and this guy showed me this tactic where
when you're skinning it,
you get your knife sharpened,
make your initial cuts,
and then he doles the tip on the,
on the concrete.
And so when he seen him,
because what it is,
he'll skin healing skin closer to the,
essentially closer to the skin and keep all the fat on the pork,
which normally if you just kind of skin it off,
take the hide off,
all the fats removed.
But he said that if you leave that fat on it just,
it gives it a lot more flavor,
a different flavor.
And he's really good.
I did it and it was,
it was pretty exciting.
What's the difference in the flavor?
Like could you describe it?
It's more like regular pork I would say.
Hmm.
Yeah,
more of a,
do you know who Joel Salitan is?
No.
So kind of a famous farmers get some really unique ideas about farming and he
was a guest on the podcast as well.
And what he does is he lets his pigs kind of run wild.
He sets up,
I'll go large electric fence and he moves that electric fence all over the
place.
So these pigs,
the way they eat is they route,
they eat acorns and they eat,
they eat like a normal pig would and there's plenty of food in the forest but
they keep them intact,
uh,
in a,
in a certain area where the,
with this portable electric fence,
so they just kept moving the fence.
It's like the pigs will,
you know,
route out this area and you know,
forge in this one area and then those kind of move them to another spot and then
they'll let them forage in that area.
And so these pigs have a dark meat,
like a wild boar.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's good.
It's,
it isn't like domestic import,
but I,
I almost prefer it if you try it,
if it next time you get one,
try to leap,
Cook a little bit with the skin on a that's good.
Really with the skin on,
we just,
you just burned the start a big fire and get some water and just sharing the
hair off.
Yeah.
And then cook with the skin on all bone it out
first and you can stuff like stuff the ham with.
I don't know.
Some kind of stuffing,
whatever you want,
really,
and then put it in the oven roast in the oven like that.
You don't eat the skin.
But I've seen people do that with domestic pig,
so she would do those,
those big whole pig roasts.
Oh yeah,
that looks upset.
Yeah.
Alex Oss,
we tried doing that for a buddy's bachelor party,
but we didn't get the fire hot enough.
So we're all here camping by this lake and I brought this big pig and I'm all
excited about it,
get it out.
And now we all have raw pig.
So he fired up the grills and then made the best out of the situation.
Everything's close.
Everything just smells like pork after.
Was it a wild pig or was it,
it wasn't domestic pig.
Yeah.
I wish it would have been a wild pig.
Well,
you have to worry less about tricking osis.
Right.
With the domestic demand,
they're actually lowering the temperature that you could cook a domestic pig.
Now the,
the recommendation,
they've got it down to 140 degrees c I have heard that the trick gnosis comes
from them eating rodents.
So technically they could get,
I mean there could be mice because they would eat the feed.
The mice would get in with the grain and everything and I can still get trick
gnosis definitely contact her.
I wouldn't quote me on that,
but I have definitely heard that a lot.
Well I've watched my chickens,
I have domestic chickens and I've watched them eat a miles.
Oh yeah,
they found a mouse in the chicken house and they fucked that thing up man.
It was wild just because usually they just kind of like know they're just like
pack in and they'll,
you know,
they get real happy if they find a snail or stuff like that.
But they found that mouse and they just stomped,
that little fucker went to town.
They went to town,
they were fighting over it and they were both,
they were all tearing it apart and you see they're wrapped or past fucking
dinosaurs stores.
That's because on apex I wanted to look at a lot.
I'm just fascinated by birds and the way they,
the way they move in hot,
especially predatory birds.
A lot of people think of birds is seed eating,
bird bath.
The animals.
Most birds are meat eaters like most divorced.
Yeah.
All right.
Well I mean there's a lot of smaller species that aren't,
but there are a lot of carnivorous birds and the way they hunt.
I'm like the Great Blue Heron.
We did an episode that'll be coming up here shortly.
The thing's got a spear attached to its head.
What other animal?
What other animals?
There's videos of great blue herons spearing these gophers.
It's unbelievable.
I want to see something like pull,
pull,
pull that up Jamie.
They have a spear on their face.
Yeah,
it's about Pelicans Pelican.
We've got a scoop scooper and it's got a net there,
but they have a builtin net.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
I rented a house in Malibu for a few months and uh,
when I was getting some fixed in my kitchen and uh,
the house was like right on the water and it was really fucking cool because I
would eat breakfast every morning,
like essentially,
like you'd look out from the kitchen table and just nothing but water.
And I'd watch these pelicans diving in and I'd watch these swarms of birds when
they'd find,
you know,
a fish feeding.
Oh yeah.
It's just,
it's so wild to be around them.
Oh,
police,
the blue heron spears a gopher.
So what does he just chilling,
waiting for it to pop its head up.
Yeah.
I don't know if this is,
oh there's like that's it.
He just walked to go for,
they catch anything but he speared it.
That's what's crazy.
Stab it.
Managing that's into your face.
Is this another one?
Yeah.
That's pretty good.
A weapon built in your face catching spearst up.
The bigger fish they'll spear other ones they grabbed.
But these gophers they definitely,
they definitely go for it.
I saw an eagle for the first time,
I guess it was two years ago now in a Alaska.
Went up their salmon fishing.
I'd never seen an eagle in the wild.
Let's see,
needles before.
But when you see one in the wild and he started going,
oh this is a,
this is not what I think it is.
Oh yeah,
this,
this is like some killer cause some flying killer that has literally has knives
on its fingers as it's floating around looking for something not snatching.
Just fuck up.
Catch.
Look at that.
Bam.
Yeah.
Just jacked that over.
It's like there's your birds.
Wow.
Kitchen gophers.
Dinosaurs.
Yeah.
They look like it.
They're pretty cool.
Yeah.
Birds are fascinating,
man.
Have you ever seen the videos of the Harpy Eagles and South America?
Oh yeah.
They're cool.
Harpy Eagles killing monkeys and sloths flying off of these sloths.
They're apparently do the biggest ego,
right?
The Harpy Eagle I believe is the biggest one.
Yeah.
Well I'm not sure.
I believe they are.
Yeah,
I think so.
Either way.
They're fucking enormous.
And so they did this a nature documentary with these guys were setting up a
camera on the Harpy Eagles nest and they had a chance.
Here goes one,
look at this.
Whew.
Poor slob.
He's just a shit deal.
Like he lives his life in slow motion and get ripped out of a tree by an eagle
and put on nat Geo wild.
Oh God.
Seriously?
What a shit deal it is to be a sloth.
Uh,
that's crazy.
Oh God.
It's amazing that they can fly with an animal that size too easy to look how he
swoops in as bitch.
Bam as cool.
It's really cheating,
you know?
Oh yeah.
I mean it's like,
I was like hunting a cow in a pen,
which is pretty cool.
It is really cool.
But it's,
it's,
that's an eagle,
you know,
I mean,
that's what we think of when we think of a bird of prey that is the
quintessential bird of prey doing this apex Predator show.
I've got to get up close and person with a lot of animals that I just think are
pretty bad ass and you to be sure.
We did one that was a Golden Eagle episode.
Oh.
And went to this lady,
she runs like this rehabilitation center raptor of the Rockies and she's gotten
all kinds of crazy raptors and there's a Golden Eagle and a bald eagle in the
same enclosure area and we got to take the Golden Eagle out and check it out.
And that the Golden Eagle is an impressive,
I mean it's quite a bit bigger than the baldy.
That's an enormous burden.
And they're native to Colorado and the out.
Yeah,
they're,
they're probably the most widely distributed eagle in North America.
I mean all the way through Mexico there and they are a crazy predator.
Yeah.
I've seen some videos of them killing wolves on,
we does the Mongolia,
the Mongolian guys.
That's bizarre.
They've trained these eagles to hunt
Wolf's for it.
That's pretty crazy.
He had said it's an enormous bird and it's really crazy to think that at one
point in time they were even larger.
You know,
they have much,
much larger birds of prey in North America.
Look at the face on that thing.
Damn those eyeballs.
Yeah.
Apparently that's what I was studying.
Their eyesight and they can spot medium sized pray from up to two miles away,
two miles.
Isn't that fun?
I mean that's the thing that,
one of the things that just so much fascinates me about animals especially is
they have capabilities that it's almost hard with all our technology to even
replicate.
If you really think about it,
there's a lot of weird stuff on this planet.
Dolphins using sonar and eagles being able to see two miles away or it was just
a lot of crazy things in nature that it's taken us years and years to replicate
some kind of machine or contraption where we can even compare it to it and in
some cases we haven't even come close like this smell that a bloodhound can pick
up.
Exactly.
Smelling things that have been there ages ago and we don't have any idea like
we don't have any idea how to make a piece of equipment that can smell something
in the distance the way a dog can with dogs.
I mean,
Kim,
I would just love to wonder.
I would love to experience what are they,
what's going on inside their nose when they,
when they catch a scent,
like what is that?
What are they catching all we're a bird walked.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
they're,
they say that the comparison is a with skunk spray because with skunk spray,
a person can pick up parts per million in a way that you can't with any other
spray with any of smell.
Rather like a,
when you're driving down the street,
like there's this area near my house and as I'm driving on my way home,
I smell sconsin this one spot all the time and they're probably blocks away from
me,
but I smelled them so clearly.
Like I rolled down the window.
Like you could sleep up there right there and they were there days ago probably.
Yeah,
it could be or it could be.
Well,
they're definitely not right there.
They're probably blocks away from me.
There's nothing else that I could think of that,
that small that you could smell blocks away.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
They say that that's kind of like a dog,
but way better.
Like they know where it is.
Then I'll just go,
fuck,
what is that?
They go,
oh,
it's over there.
It's over there.
Yeah,
Dude.
Like I think it's,
you can make,
make them smell a dude socks.
And then he hit my,
they'll know he's over there and they can chase his ass down just like you could
smell skunk.
They could smell a person like that.
It's fucking
crazy.
So if,
have you been elk hunting yet?
Not yet.
One of the things I always tell people is,
especially if you haven't been helping most of the elk that we end up killing,
I attribute to smelling him first and people that don't,
elk hunt would never pick up on it.
But I'm hunting with my knows almost as much as I'm using any other tactic.
Really.
Oh yeah.
And I'll,
I'll,
I always keep a lighter in my pocket and as soon as I pick up the scent,
if flipped the lighter on and see which way the wind's going because you'll
catch it.
Like if the wind blows first split second or swirls,
you'll smell it and you can get right in.
And I,
I can distinguish the difference between the smell of an elk and we're an Alex
Ben,
you can actually smell it in elks urinated right here where there's a wall low
and there's a different smell between that.
And the smell of an animal.
So I'll tell my clients will say,
I smell an elk lake,
a physical animal.
Get be ready.
It's,
it's within x amount of distance.
And just through practice you can,
you can decipher those things.
What is,
is there a way you could describe it?
Like it was the smelling,
so I s uh,
smells are the hardest thing on the planet.
Describe uh,
an,
an elk smells a lot like a beef cow,
but there's a different,
a different note to it and the,
the smell of on say a bowl.
A live animal.
It's a,
it's a weird,
it almost smells hot.
I don't know how to describe it,
but you can,
you can smell the difference.
It's stronger and it,
it just smells different.
Hot.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know.
It's like if the very end of the scent you can,
you can pick it up.
Does their smell vary based on whether or not they're in the Rut?
Yeah,
it does.
Well,
the intensity of their smell varies.
The A cow.
A cow elk will smell different when she's in heat or during the Rut.
Same with meal deer.
You'll smell meal deer as well.
Well,
I know when we hunted mule deer,
a Renault was telling us don't touch the tarsal gland cause that gland you,
if you get that on you or if you get it on the,
especially if you get it on the immediate thing,
it just fucks up everything.
Yeah.
But does that smell like
smells like musty dear?
Just like funk.
Yeah.
Funk dear funk.
And you can,
have you ever got it on the meat before?
No,
not that I know.
If I did have one mule deer that I shot during the Rut,
uh,
with my recurve bow and it was not as good as other deer,
it was probably one of the worst tasting deer in.
So maybe I did somehow.
Huh?
Cause I thought I was eating it and going,
this tastes like they smell.
It's usually tie make sausage.
Usually they smell right,
it tastes good,
tastes awesome.
But that must,
it could have been that.
It just could have been,
I don't know.
Who knows really?
What is a,
if you doing this show,
what has been the most surprising thing when you're analyzing all these
different animals in their hunting tactics?
I think the most surprising thing is humans have a natural innate ability
hunting ability that is very comparable to animals that have to hunt to survive.
And I say that like we,
one of the,
one of the things that really brought this to light was one of our last episodes
of the season.
We look at the River Otter River on it.
Well it's a mammal that hunts underwater.
We're mammals can we hunt underwater?
And I'm pretty much from the desert.
So water is people are in the water,
but I think of it as something that people have trained their whole lives to do
or whatever,
you know,
be efficient,
free diving.
So I go to Florida and kind of just try to uncover how humans compared to
mammals at hunter water.
It turns out we have the same guy reflexes in other things as other mammals that
hunter under water and we,
anybody off the street can initiate these,
these reflexes thing that our trouble is,
is our mind.
We have this mental threshold that we have to get over.
But once we get over that,
within two hours,
I was able to hold my breath for over four minutes.
What crazy.
What's all the mentee?
You're in really good shape.
No,
this is the guy that I did this free diving course and the guy is like,
we could take,
if,
if everyone could just block mental things out of their mind,
pretty much the average person off the street could easily hold their breath for
three minutes.
And if you could completely clear your mind,
pretty much everyone could hold their breath for three or four to five minutes.
That's insane.
It's crazy.
So it's just the panic,
the freaking out.
Like I gotta breathe,
you gotta breathe.
But there,
there's this mammalian dive reflex in it.
It restricts your capillaries,
slows your heart rate automatically.
Uh,
your,
your spleen releases more red blood cells so your body consumes less oxygen.
It's the exact same thing that happens in whales,
dolphins,
auditors.
So we're just born with these predators,
these things that other male other predators have.
And it kind of really comes out in this TV show and that that's one of the
things that I really wanted to do this because looking at it and talking about
it,
he say,
what,
what are you doing?
And at the onset it sounds completely ridiculous,
especially to a guy like me that made most of my life hunting.
So I go,
okay,
well what am I doing here?
I'm,
I'm trying to dissect nature and see his hunting really something that's natural
for humans to do.
Are we meant to be hunters?
Are we born to be hunters?
And obviously there's a big learning curve in it,
but there we are very similar to these other animals that are born predators.
What the only makes sense if buffalo
have a natural instinct to avoid by pedal hominids cause they've seen that,
okay,
they get shot or get killed and they know that wolves come around.
Okay.
Don't run,
stay put,
and we'll fuck these wolves up.
Like it almost seems like all this information just gets passed on somehow or
another through genetics.
And that's how these animals,
uh,
managed to be here.
We would only make sense that if we've gotten to 2015 the way we got here is by
eating everything that we could eat up til now,
including every animal that we could figure out how to hunt and all those skills
and all those abilities.
Especially the idea that your spleen starts releasing extra red blood when you
dive under water to allow you to stay.
There's only one reason to stay underwater.
It's to to,
to hide from something or to kill some things.
That's it.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Wow.
That's pretty wild.
So what did you do when you,
when you did that you,
we use a spear or something like that.
So yeah.
Then I went,
we went out into the Gulf of Mexico and,
and spirits and greater amberjack and diving down pretty deep.
And it was,
it was awesome.
It's so cool.
How long was the longest she stayed down while moving?
So the static breath holds or you're doing four minute breath holds.
And when I got up from those that you feel this kind of euphoric sense,
you're like,
wow.
And you get up and you people black out at the top because they forget to take a
breath because at that point you get to a certain point where you,
you get up and you're like,
you aren't out at,
you aren't really out of breath.
It's a mental thing.
It's a horrible feeling.
Like I know why,
but it is a mental thing because you realize your body doesn't,
it tells you it needs oxygen,
but it essentially doesn't,
well it does at some point,
but there's people that will hold their breath for 12 minutes,
12 minutes.
Well,
didn't that,
that Dude David Blaine,
right?
He did something where he took like oxygen in.
He did something,
he did some sort of a sneaky trick where he,
uh,
he breathed in pure oxygen and held it and held his breath like 17 minutes or
something.
Right?
Yeah.
This is before he did that stunt.
This is the same thing that he went through to prepare for it.
Oh really?
Yeah,
so he went through through free diving.
Yeah.
Performance to name it Egan.
Anyway,
he's brothers with a guy named [inaudible] who was a famous a MMA fighter and a
Egan actually fought some MMA himself,
but Egan was a world champion free diver and I think he could hold his breath
for like seven minutes crazy living in Hawaii.
The law they would use,
I'm holding their breath underwater is it was one of the strength and
conditioning programs they would do.
They would move rocks underwater.
Bj Penn had it on one of his,
um,
one of the countdown shows to one of his big fights.
He would dive underwater and lift up a big rock and then move the rock
underwater and drop it and come back over here and go down and move it again,
drop and come back over here.
I've heard
through the grapevine that a lot of athletes are doing these breath holds before
competitions because they're,
they're naturally naturally creating more red blood cells.
Performance enhancing
breath holds.
Wow.
That makes sense.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
If,
if,
if you're saying that the spleen releases it when you're underwater,
it probably is releasing it cause you're holding your breath.
Correct.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's just,
it's going to be the new doping fuck
blood doping,
but there's a lot of,
there's a lot of athletes that are doing these,
initiating these natural responses to enhance their performance.
Yeah.
That's one of the big ones that I've been really getting into over the last few
months or a year or so actually is um,
cryogenic therapy where you go into this chamber that's 250 degrees below zero.
Wow.
You put a surgical mask on earmuffs,
on gloves.
Uh,
you have underwear on and you wear socks and like rubber crocs so that you uh,
your foot doesn't touch the bottom cause you will get frostbite.
Anything you touch,
you'll get frostbite and he stepped in this thing for 250 degrees below zero for
three minutes and you get out and you feel fucking fantastic when you get out.
You feel like you could jump over the building just wow.
You just,
everything just feels so good once your,
because your body thinks it's going to die if your body pulls all his blood
until your internal organs and when you come out they actually do a temperature
test.
The surface of your skin and the surface of my skin is usually somewhere around
30 30 to 35 degrees.
It's like it gets really cold and then immediately your blood just rushes back
to all your extremities and the anti inflammatory response is spectacular.
So people have like pretty significant injuries,
arthritis,
like even people that are like close,
borderline and needing like hip replacements.
They've been able to put it off by doing this cryotherapy and mitigate almost
all the pain.
That's pretty cool.
That's because it's funny the the Mammalian dive reflex response.
When your face hits cold water,
it starts to initiate because that's closing those capillaries and it's probably
a very similar process that's going on with that Cryo.
Then I may make sense.
I used to take cold showers like real hardcore cold showers.
When I lived in Boston,
there was this guy named Bob Calf umbrella that I used to do taekwondo with and
he was like a,
he was a senior student.
He was like ahead of me.
He was a black ball before I was,
he was like way and he was,
he was fucking mad man.
He's asleep at the gym train all day long.
He'd always see him training,
but he was also into like forcing himself to do things that he didn't like to do
it to be uncomfortable and want to do is in mid January who'd take cold showers
and it was fucking cold.
Take your talking about code 33 degree water,
you know,
it was like just barely cold enough to not be frozen in the pipes and he would
turn that shit on and he would take a shower in there and it would just breathe
in there.
I am like Ugh.
And I remember trying and I did it a few times,
but it's just like you can't,
that's the thing that freaks you out.
It's like you got no breath.
Yeah.
Why can't I breathe like,
and she made being cold makes sense.
But why can't I breathe and I guess is probably the same sort of a response.
It is.
Yeah.
Wow.
Who would think that maybe taking a really cold shower before you perform,
you know,
before you do anything athletic would,
would benefit you as well?
I would think so.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of things that nature can teach us that,
you know,
our bodies just do
what was,
what was the motivation to do this show?
Because this is a very different than solo hunter,
which is how I found out about you,
which is really cool show.
Uh,
it's still round you if you guys want to catch some episodes and in that show
you would go out by yourself.
Just bring cameras and really fascinating stuff.
And I'm,
and I'm still doing that show and I don't really plan on changing anything with
that because I still,
my bread and butter is going out and hunting.
It's what I love.
But I wanted to get a little bit deeper and do something different and buy
something different.
I wanted to also do something that looks at hunting in any person watching the
show,
whether they're a hunter,
not could look at this and go,
you know what?
There's something here.
There's something that shows me that humans are meant to be hunters.
If and,
and if I can make one person think that and go,
okay,
well maybe,
maybe hunting isn't so bad.
Then for me that's,
that's a bonus because it's something that I love.
I don't want to see hunting go away because if I did,
then that's,
that's my passion.
That's what I'm all about.
So if all of a sudden it disappeared wasn't allowed or whatever,
people didn't understand it,
then for me,
I feel like I don't know what I would do.
Is that really possible though?
No,
I,
it could be.
I mean you never really know because it's not guaranteed.
There's just like mountain lion hunting isn't allowed in California.
It makes no sense ecologically or whatever.
If people's emotions get involved with management or whatever,
it just seems like change California.
Such an extreme example of people who don't have experience with wildlife.
We're making those choices or definitely don't have experience with hunting.
Yeah.
The whole department of fish and game out here isn't fishing game.
It's fishing wildlife.
It's in the few states that has a distinction in the way labels itself.
But the other reason is I
professionally might,
I've made my living hunting and there's always been this idea for me of kind of
taking it deeper.
And in this show I actually learned something every time I do.
One of these is as ridiculous as the premise might be or whatever we're trying
to do.
Seemed ridiculous to me sometimes at first.
And then I go through the steps and I really learned something and if I can
learn something,
I've been doing this forever,
then I feel like other people watching can learn something.
Other hunters,
other people in general.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Um,
I think
just the hunting itself is a learning experience.
There's so many bad ideas that people have or are just bad con misconceptions
about hunting.
And a lot of it comes down to,
we look at hunting or people look at hunting.
A lot of times they look at the negative aspects of like trophy hunting,
trophy hunting seems kind of gross to people.
Like they're,
the recent one was that lady was laying down next to a giraffe.
Yeah I saw.
That's just really,
it's just poor taste,
poor management,
poor thinking like you,
you really,
you could keep going on and on forever.
Like why would you lie down next to a giraffe smiling,
you know there's the whole thing is is very strange and w the real fuck up about
it is that it puts out this image that confuses the real issue at hand,
which is this was a large non breeding male that they were going to take out
anyway.
Like this was,
they had already deemed through their conservation efforts that they were going
to take this,
this giraffe out and that they were going to use it to feed these villagers.
So her paying money to go and shoot this thing actually helps all these
villagers,
it gives them food.
Then they take the money,
they can apply the money to,
you know,
whatever,
making wells or whatever they do with the money that they get from,
um,
from hunter's paying to hunt these animals.
There's a benefit to it because that animal wasn't going to be around much
longer anyway,
her stepping in and go,
but then,
but then when you put it on Facebook and you're smiling and you're,
it's all so fucking confusing.
Like to everybody else that goes,
well,
you're an asshole.
You just shot a fucking giraffe jr who eats giraffes?
You know,
like,
no,
no one's,
you're not like going over there to feed your family by shooting giraffes.
And then you find out,
well,
you actually can eat drafts and actually drafts tastes like a lot of different
animals.
They're related to meet.
Yeah,
they're deer.
They're essentially crazy necked antelopes right?
Isn't that what they're their family,
their,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean antelopes are delicious.
But giraffes are so nice.
You go to the zoo.
You know,
I had this bit in my last special about giraffes being like the only animal that
I don't feel bad there at the zoo.
Yeah.
Cause they wake up and they're like on another day with no lions and they just
wander around like having a great old time.
Like we're so confident that giraffes are nice that they let babies feed them.
Yeah.
Like when my daughter was two,
I was holding her up in my arms and she's got her little tiny little baby hand
out with a piece of lettuce and the giraffe comes over,
wraps its tongue around the lettuce and takes and she's laughing and like
they're so confident at the zoo in the giraffes behavior at Dell had babies feed
them,
which is crazy.
In the wild though,
giraffes can be like a Bolger African be pretty dangerous animal because
probably because of their size.
But if you,
I've seen drafts fighting their necks and wham and did you use their weapon?
They whip their head into each other,
but they're uh,
you know,
I think people assume too,
like,
oh,
drafts.
Really.
It would be really easy to kill because they're so big.
And I got this,
uh,
I was working in South Africa and on this place there was a future apps there
and they would get this disease from ticks.
And so the guy would hire these professional hunters like myself or whatever to
shoot,
like inoculate the giraffes with these paint fill with like,
um,
uh,
we call it douse or drench.
It's kills parasites.
So it's a paintball gun.
So you have to get closer than you would with a bow and sneak up on these
drafts.
The drafts were the hardest thing on the place to inoculate.
Oh yeah.
Because they can see you coming forever.
And they were skittish because they just,
they wanted these drafts to survive and to have the drafts had actually gotten
killed by power lines.
So there's only a few giraffes.
There's a big windstorm and two giraffes,
boom,
zapped dead.
Oh,
the lines came down and cook them.
Whoa.
I don't know if that,
how it happened or what,
just whipping in the wind and killed both of them.
Whoa.
But,
so the guy was really set on inoculate or dowsing these giraffes.
So I went out there and I don't know why because a lot I would,
there was a lot of other animals in this area that just weren't accustomed to
the ticks there because they might've been from another region and they kind of
do this on these giant,
I don't even know what you call him,
preserves in Africa.
If you go on a photo safari in South Africa or whatever,
it's essentially there's places where say they bring in animals and maybe that
animal wasn't indigenous to that region,
but they swapped with this game reserve area over here to kind of integrate
breeding and keep the populations existing.
And so you bring in a giraffe to this portion of Africa that maybe hasn't had
your ass for,
who knows how long and the ticks there will kill him.
They get these diseases from the ticks.
So,
but there was a lot of other animals like that too.
So I'd go out at night or whatever and try to shoot these animals antelope with
paintballs that would actually kill the ticks.
And I never saw the drafts at night.
I don't know why.
Maybe I just,
it was kind of weird.
You'd think you'd find them
trees,
but maybe they're laying down.
Maybe that's why I didn't find them.
I don't know why I couldn't figure that out.
But they were the hardest things to shoot with a paintball gun.
So there it is.
Drafts paintballing drafts is one of the hardest things I've ever had to do.
Those wild game preserves and Africa.
Boy,
that is a goddamn conundrum and if there's any ever anything that's stirred up
the,
the sort of the horrible feelings anti hunters have,
it's those game preserves.
We could just go there
and just kill these animals and it's such a catch 22 because these animals,
a lot of them were bordering on being extinct just a couple of decades ago and
now their populations are thriving,
but the vast majority of them are in these high fence game operations.
It's real weird.
Well,
even in the places that aren't sh hunting where they just are for photo safaris
or what have you,
you get,
say you bring in,
I'll pick a species cooch way kudu.
There you go.
So you bring in Kudu to displace where it could be 200,000 acres and people are
going to come and take pictures of these animals.
Well,
if there's no hunting there,
even with the lions and other things that they have there,
the Kudu pop,
one of these populations may explode.
They cannot sustain themselves.
They have to manage these areas too.
So a lot of times they do game captures or they may allow some hunting that the
people taking photos don't even know about.
But whenever you have these populations,
it's just,
it's the same as managing animals in the state of Montana.
Just on a smaller scale.
You know you have a limited amount of food supply,
you have x amount of animals.
These populations are growing at this rate.
The predators are only taking care of this much.
Therefore excess has to be taken care of.
And some of those excess animals are animals that used to be near extinction and
now if you don't manage them,
they'll,
they'll all die off of wherever they're at.
That's so crazy.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's so crazy.
Also the,
this is a giant booming economy in Africa now.
Oh yeah.
And,
and all that.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a business on multilevels too because the land owner now owns the meat.
So then he'll either sell the meat or give it to people living there,
working there.
Yeah.
If you go over to Africa to hunt,
you can't really bring that meat back.
Kenya.
Nah,
but you can't in New Zealand.
Yep.
Can you,
and you can hose up a New Zealand's clean.
They don't have anything that we don't have.
So you can't,
you couldn't bring meat into New Zealand,
but you can bring me out of New Zealand.
Okay.
So you don't have to worry about some funky new type thing.
They don't have anything.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It's funny.
It bulla,
the,
one of my friends is a professional hunter in South Africa and a lot of people
didn't want to go to Africa after they heard the Ebola.
Well from Africa is such a large continent from where he is to where the bullet
is is further away than Atlanta,
Georgia.
Wow.
Not to Americans for Africa.
The same shit.
One over there.
They all got aids from the monkeys.
Yeah.
We don't realize how big it is.
We,
we did an image on the podcast recently.
We uh,
we pulled up,
there's an image of Africa,
the continent and how enormous it is and how other continents
you could stuff inside of Africa.
And it's so shocking when you,
when you realize how big it really is because on a map,
there it is right there.
Look,
China,
United States,
India,
Eastern Europe and a bunch of other shit in there too.
I mean all of it just stuffed in there.
The UK,
everything stuffed in there.
Jam packed.
That's crazy.
That's nuts.
That's a cool picture.
It's a very cool picture.
This is a,
God damn sure.
Which country are huge continent rather.
That's the other thing is Africa.
People think of,
it's like United States,
African Africa,
you know,
it's the fucking continent man.
Different facets and people and problems and solutions and a huge spot of
controversy now for hunting and this,
this whole trophy hunting thing.
Rinella wrote a great piece about it.
The,
the,
the really,
he wrote an amazing piece about,
um,
the woman as these young girls that are getting involved in hunting and it's
like become a career for a lot of them.
They look real pretty and they go over there and shoot animals and pose with
them and all the pro hunters get on their side and all the anti hunters have,
or Facebooks and death threats and it's like,
it's almost like a dance that everyone's doing.
But what he wrote about it,
which I,
I thought it was really fascinating.
It was like,
I think a lot of this is sexism.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
Right?
Yeah.
You're dealing with is pretty blonde.
Who goes over there and shoots all these animals.
If it was a fat old guy from Denmark,
nobody would give a fuck.
It wouldn't be storming that guy's Facebook page.
People would find it distasteful that he shall lie and like an asshole.
But that would be where it ends.
It's because,
yeah,
it's because it's women and,
and as much as it's the same people,
it's kind of a hypocritical way to look at it too,
because they,
they go,
oh,
there's a lot of the people that are doing this.
Maybe it's just me being hypocritical as well,
but a lot of the people that do it probably look at him as a women and go,
you know,
if it's a man,
it's different because hunting's a man's sport and they see these pretty girls
doing it and they,
if they're out of place or something,
whereas hunters don't even think like that.
It's like,
oh,
a woman hunting.
Yeah.
That's great.
Well,
you know what it is too.
I think it's also that they're attractive white women with blonde hair.
You just think all these evil thoughts of racism and cruelty and just these
monster Arion women that are shooting animals and posing with a big stupid
whitened teeth.
Smiles.
Yeah.
It is a form of sexist.
I,
I feel like now on the flip side,
some of them probably just,
I mean it's the easy,
if you wanted to jump in that spotlight,
go shoot yourself align and where a cheerleader,
I'm actually planning on doing that next week.
They show little blow up Apex Predator.
It was
cheerleader outfit.
Have my pom poms and go out and chase them lines.
That's what you need to do.
You need to take over the transgender hunting markets.
It's right.
If you became the first openly transgender or hunting or at least trends across
trash stressor,
not transgender,
that trickles down.
I don't want to get to that deep into it.
When you start pulling out a scalpel and removing balls on
the endocrine system,
there's a lot going on there by the Cno hills in heels,
just a new one.
All my accounts,
cancer now solo hunters and I've used to get these stilettos letters,
pumps.
I'm really pumped for this adventure.
I wonder how many gay hunters or are two.
That was something that we,
we'd gotten into before we were trying to describe like the average hunter and I
said,
well how many people like,
you know,
like a lot of hunters tend to lean right wing and maybe that's because of gun
rights or second amendment ideas or just because it's like sort of a
traditional,
you know,
God guns and you know,
grills grilling.
I'm kind of going,
but they tend to like,
like I would say the majority,
I would say it's probably like more than 60% or right wing.
Yeah,
I'd probably say that.
Yeah.
But how many of them are gay?
I don't know.
Do you know any gay hunters?
I do.
You do?
Ah,
there you go.
I know a few of them that are actually guides like professional hundred.
Really?
Are they open?
Not,
no.
I mean they just tell you,
hey man,
you don't want to share a tent with me cause I will fuck you.
That's one of,
in one of those.
No,
I mean,
there I,
yeah,
I don't really know why wouldn't he just know that they're gay.
Yeah.
And it just doesn't come up.
I think in this day and age it's more about,
I mean,
not that this needs to be discussed in depth,
but I think homosexuality,
it's more like if you really do care,
unless you're dealing with some extremely aggressive individual that's like
annoying with his gayness.
Right?
Like you just won't take no for an answer.
Which I have seen.
I have seen,
I know a comedian like that,
he's fucking brutal,
was not so brutal anymore.
He's an older gentleman.
I believe he's going to calm down.
But back in the day,
like maybe 10 15 years ago,
I had a deal with them one night at a drunken bar and Montreal.
I was like,
dude,
you gotta get the fuck away from me.
Like I'm not gay.
You got to stop.
She was brutal,
you know,
like trying to be trying to get this other dude to come upstairs and then he's
like,
what about you?
I'm like,
come on man,
get outta here.
Like you just,
you just brutal like you,
you realize what it's like to be a woman.
They have some,
I'm not a piece of meat.
You can stand.
Eyes are up here,
these holes top looking at my nonfunctional breasts,
but then he started,
then he started to insult you and you're kinda like,
well,
what's wrong with me?
Latch.
Yeah.
He'd put starts playing mind games and then you start wanting them.
I just,
I,
I w I think in this day and age,
just because there's gonna come a point in time where the person that is
homophobic or racist or in any other prejudice,
that person is going to be like very rare,
very rare and like despised.
Like right now it's,
there's plenty of people that you
could hang out with that would share in your racism or share in your homophobia.
But I think because of the Internet,
because people are kind of understanding people a little bit better and
motivations a little bit better,
that's going to be less and less.
Yeah.
I think if more gay hunters were around,
I think that would help.
So you gave his blog,
they're a great way to get in.
Fabulous.
First.
As far as that stuff,
that's a touchy one though.
Even people that like to eat meat,
they're like,
I have a hard time with furs.
Right?
Yeah.
For is it tricky?
They are falls into like sort of the same ideas of trophy hunting.
Like you're,
you're,
you're turning an animal into an object.
Even people that didn't meet have a problem with first or first or leathers,
I guess lenders because you're eating the animal underneath it.
Well,
I look,
I could wear these fucking converse to wholefoods.
No single Vegan.
Oh,
give me a heart.
There's a leather,
you know,
nobody would give me a hard time about these.
Yeah,
that'd be fine.
Leather belt,
no one's going to get crazy.
Is that leather interior in your car?
No one gives a fuck.
No one cares.
But if you say that you eat an animal that's not on the average every day menu,
you know,
if you're one of those weird dudes do go squirrel hunting,
all you piece of shit.
How could you shoot a squirrel?
Would,
would uh,
what is her analysis term?
He uses?
Um,
um,
charismatic megafauna like bears.
Bears are a big one.
People think of Yogi and booboo and all these different animals.
It's,
yeah,
we've given,
we've given human personalities to,
to non humans.
Yeah,
so we attached to them,
but Bullwinkle never caught down.
Nobody gives a fuck if you shoot a moose,
they really don't care.
Rocky because of the squirrel.
Squirrel.
That's fine.
Well,
what's the cross?
A cute,
fluffy.
They like the most acceptable road in ever.
I don't,
yeah,
I think they're just kind of big,
noisy rats.
Really.
I don't even,
I've eaten coyote coyote before.
I ate a squirrel.
Really?
I've never eaten squirrels.
I don't know why.
You've never even tried it.
I not that I wouldn't,
but in my,
where I grew up.
Squirrels.
You just didn't eat squirrels.
Well,
you got your coyote the same place I got my squirrel from Rinella,
Dj some squirrels.
Again,
I feel like I shouldn't go through my life without eating a squirrel.
I hate a pigeon.
The other day we had pigeons on our roof and they were just crapping all over,
so I shot it with a pellet gun or
whatever.
It's me.
It's like,
well,
yeah.
I feel like when you,
when you utilize it,
then it's okay.
It kind of it for myself.
It justifies it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
yeah,
he's a,
it was like now if I trap a rat and garage and I can eat that
unless you're really hungry.
I was in New York City last week and they had pigeon on the menu at a
restaurant.
We ate,
I call it squad.
Nope.
It was pitched and it just said pigeon it.
See that's some animals get weird.
There's like a weird stipulation with them where it's not a tasty edible item,
but no.
If you put dove there,
duck hunters love gfes,
but pigeons are tabbing.
Hunters love dogs,
but if you had dove on a menu in a regular restaurant,
the average person who's not a hunter would,
he's full bird.
It's the piece bird of love.
That's the love bird.
He has the twig in its hand.
I start the love bird was the swallow.
I don't know.
That's not the love.
That's the less burlesque bird.
Yeah,
it's just a dirty bird that's,
I forgot.
Yeah.
The patients were actually brought to North America as a food source.
When you look at pigeons that are in New York and they're flying all over the
buildings and shitting all over the place,
those pigeons were initially brought over as a food source.
They are nonnative animals.
My great grandma raised pigeons for food wine sold and that was like that was
there.
Their pigeon farmers squabbling sales.
Wow.
Squad salesman.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Cause I'd seen it.
You see it in a few Chinese food restaurants,
squad salad and other things,
but they have to call it squad.
If you don't call,
if you call it Cajun.
This.
That's why I was amazed at this New York City restaurant,
but they're just,
New York City is on some next level culinary type shit.
I mean that's like,
that's locally sourced man.
That's paging from it.
Yeah,
I can see that.
It's from my jungle,
the jungle of my rooftop apartment.
Yeah.
There's uh,
a lot of them.
If you want to serve pigeons in New York,
that's like,
you've got a sustainable sort of an environment and they're fed well to dare eat
lots of garbage.
Probably not good for you.
They used to say that,
um,
lobster was like a poor person's food in New York.
Like way back in the day.
They used to,
when people wanted lobsters,
they would get them directly from the river.
They'll get them right from the East River and they would pull him out and they
would serve them in bars and they were like poor people food or just cause
they're aqua cockroaches.
Yeah.
Well they literally are a rack.
Spiders,
if you have an allergy to shellfish,
you also have an allergy to roaches.
We found that out on fear factor.
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
People that were allergic to shellfish,
we gave them roaches and their,
their throat started season.
Oh cause they're eating the roaches in the rather show where it's like,
oh cockroach over here.
Oh yeah,
they're ingesting base.
We,
I did can't believe that.
No one knew that.
Like they,
they would ask people what are your allergies?
And they said shellfish.
Okay.
Eat a roach.
Same fucking thing,
man.
You're making anybody going to like Anna Filactic.
Shocker.
He's,
this guy got real close.
He was whistling.
Ooh,
his mouth was a windpipe was closing down.
Did you do when someone's dying for meeting Cockroach,
do even,
do you kind of like shit talk.
I'm still like you scared.
Come on man,
suck it up.
It was much later after the show.
Yeah.
They had eaten the cockroach.
They'd gone back to the hotel and that's when the reaction started kicking in.
It wasn't an instantaneous reaction,
so I don't know if maybe they have a less strong reaction from eating the
cockroach and they do from eating shellfish or if that's how they're,
the reaction normally is,
I guess there's levels.
Allergies,
right?
Yeah.
Some people are like acutely,
like I have my friend Gary,
he can't even come over my house because I have cats.
If he opens my door,
I was just stuck.
He literally can't even breathe the air inside my house,
but my wife's allergic to cats and she lives,
she's fine.
She just has to wash her hands.
If they touch her,
they liquor or they get there.
They had the cats have to be clean.
We have to bathe them.
Hmm.
My friend Gary can't even walk in the door,
so I guess it's like there's levels of it.
Yeah.
Let's put that on cockroach allergy.
Is there a game animals that are people who are allergic to?
Is there any animal?
Have you ever heard of a person being allergic to like venison or something?
Well,
I know and I'm kind of,
I'm allergic to antelope in a certain way.
I greet him,
skinning it,
the blood.
When it dries,
it get hives.
Itchy.
Some people to get that.
Only antelope.
Yeah.
Did you ever get it checked?
No.
Huh?
I don't know,
but I mean cook it,
eat it all the time.
I love antelope meat,
so I don't know.
But I've heard,
I've talked to other people that that happens to you.
If you had to say like,
what is your all time favorite meat if somebody restricted you to one meet for
the rest of your life.
Tough.
Probably elk.
Yeah,
I is this just something about elk.
It's delicious and healthy and it's good.
It's really good.
It's such a majestic animal too.
I've only seen a few of them in the wild,
but every time I see him and just like,
whoa.
And it's fun animal to,
I mean it's so hard animal to hunt.
A lot of people don't realize,
but the payoffs amazing because it's pretty large and some of the best meat
around.
I really,
I keep coming back to no is the best.
Yeah,
it's very,
very delicious.
You know,
it's,
it's enormous animal.
Like what's the biggest elk you've ever shot?
Bodywise bodywash.
Oh this year on me and my brother drew tags on southwest of fog neck island up
in Alaska and we shot these elk.
They mine,
no joke.
Probably weighed 1400 pounds.
Hold.
It was this,
now this is for people like most [inaudible] are about 400 pounds,
like rocky mountain l average,
you know,
younger bull.
I think the,
what was it?
Wyoming did a study and it's around their 400 and something pounds is the
average elk.
Wait,
this was a very large animal and the fishing game department in Alaska sends out
a thing saying these elk are about the size of Moose.
And yes,
this elk was as big.
We're bigger than any moose I've ever packed out,
taken apart.
It was,
it was a brutal experience to say the least.
Carry it.
Oh yeah.
We had to pack this thing.
It was crazy.
Weak,
lower back.
Just start throwing.
Me and my brother,
we both shot,
we both shot bulls.
Mine was quite a bit larger body wise and my brothers,
but
eight days of just straight toil,
hundred plus pound packs,
eight days of just caring.
We filmed a documentary style show on this.
Oh it's not anything yet,
but we did.
We recorded all our,
our trip meaning in a documentary fashion and recorded on his gps are elevation
because we camped on this one,
like can we had to climb up this big mountain down the next one and we shot
these elk a ways away and it was,
I hate pulling,
I'm so bad with numbers.
I always remember Mr Representatives,
I'm trying to think here,
but it was something like 60 man hours of packing between the two of us,
30 hour,
you know,
30 hours of just straight carrying.
Holy Fuck.
It was,
it was.
I got and I got really sick on that trip and I think it might have been
partially due to just being physically done,
just Roy destroyed it was,
it was one of the most physical trips I've ever had.
But it was probably one of the best trips I've ever had.
And we came back with
600 pounds of boned out,
meet a hand,
get this,
uh,
we,
we put the meat up in a tree because we had to do cashes.
I mean this is a multiple day or deal.
So we're doing these caches and this island has some of the largest brown bears
in the world and we got them up in this one spruce trees high as we could get,
um,
probably 14,
15 feet up and two of the hindquarters in our cash got eaten by bears by a bear.
And they say these bears don't climb trees.
I don't necessarily believe that.
I think that they can get up a tree in some fashion because I don't think it was
a 16.
I know it wouldn't have been a 16 foot bear,
but somehow this bear got the meat out of this cash.
And so we came back with 600 pounds of meat minus two hindquarters.
Oh Shit.
Sane and the hindquarters or burned out or no?
Yeah,
boned out.
No bones and just meet.
Wow.
A hundred percent meat.
We took a picture where we got the plane,
we had to take two plane trips to get the meat out.
Just stacks of meat.
So how far were you traveling?
Like as the crow flaws?
I love saying by as the crow flies,
five miles as the crow flies,
but you're going up and down.
So quite a bit more than that.
From camp.
The summit was 2,500 feet from our camp vertical up.
So it's 5,000 each.
5,000 some of in one in my brothers we had to go even over two ranges like that.
So just to get one trip back,
it was 10,000 vert fuck just we documented the whole thing cause it was just
ridiculous.
And so I got sick and I don't know if it was from drinking water,
but sometimes the gestation period of a lot of things you pick up.
I did drink out of one stream that my brother didn't and it might have been
below an elk wallow.
Anyways,
I get sick and it happens to be this night that we had an insane walked back.
We got back,
I think there's one in the morning and we could have bivy out,
but the thought was we set up a base camp and if you Bibi out,
you carry your camp on your back but then you still have to get all the meat
back.
And it was
in our minds easier to just do extra effort if we had to come out light and then
we would have room to carry meat so we wouldn't have to carry our gear and other
things.
And with the bears as well,
I mean these bears are everywhere.
So we have a electric bear fence around our base camp.
Whoa.
And the night we come back and I just got super sick as gale force winds,
70 mile an hour winds.
And,
um,
and you're just trying not,
you're trying to hold throwing up the coming out both ends essentially.
And so worst time ever.
So you probably had giardia or stuff like that.
I don't think it was just something maybe kind of food boy something,
but it had to have been bacterial in some way because uh,
I had one of those,
z is the z pack,
three antibiotic things and I just so happen to throw it in.
I normally do,
but it was a lucky deal cause I took it out of my carry on through it and thing
and I've,
it's been in my kit forever and I've never had to use it and that helped.
I don't know how I would've done it because I was able to still take that and
kind of kill off whatever was going on and then finish your packing out or,
so you're talking about 30 plus hours of just packing lead and carrying it?
Yeah.
And each pack you're more than a hundred pounds right on your back.
Yeah,
man,
I was,
my brother's,
my brother's in really good shape and he's a bigger guy than me.
So carrying the same amount of weight for me,
and this is my little brother,
I can't,
he can't carry more weight than me.
Uh,
I hope he doesn't listen to this because I was hurting.
I didn't have to know it,
but I was
still hurt from it.
It's like a competition to see who breaks for exactly.
Who could deal with the hardship better.
Exactly.
And he's a,
I mean,
if I'm in,
if I'm ever in a wilderness hard situation,
like that's the guy I want in my corner.
He's just an awesome dude.
And,
and,
and because of it,
it ended up being one of the coolest trips ever.
And while we're hiking,
the thing we do,
you're just like walking and working hard.
And all we do is talk about how few calories where we,
we memorize the amount of calories and every mountain house that was our thing
is mountain house.
Those meals.
It's freeze dried meals,
meals,
and when you're over exerting and just eating freeze dried meals,
nothing is better than some fresh elk stake over the fire.
I was hanging out with this photographer when we went moose hunting.
This guys say I'm,
and he was talking about um,
this trip that he had went on where they had not brought enough food and
everyone on the trip had lost like 30 pounds,
20 pounds to lose so much weight.
So when I first started guiding every year I would loose 20th,
30 pounds.
Wow.
There's starving.
You're starving.
Yeah.
It's essentially starvation essentially.
You force your body to keep going and it starts eating off fat and muscle and it
doesn't take much to do cause you,
you almost to a point
when you're working so hard that you physically can't,
you just get sick of eating almost you,
they need some better hierarchy.
You just need to bring sticks of butter
or something like that.
Does actual fat realistically,
Yeah.
When people say that I can't lose weight,
man,
I can't,
we use way.
You're not trying to have you.
You've just test is what you need to do.
Get one of those Tenzing packs.
Throw a fucking rock in it like Cameron Hanes does,
and go climb up a mountain.
He puts 130 pound rock and his path.
It's one of the ways he prepares for elk season.
He puts a rock in his pack and he hikes up mountains.
I saw he did.
I was on Facebook or something.
Uh,
he just did the Boston marathon for a guy in his like bodybuilders status to run
like that is Semyon human really?
That mother fucker works hard.
Oh yeah,
he does it.
He lives it.
He lifts weights every day,
seven days a week.
I go,
how many days you work out every day.
Every day.
He never took a day off.
It doesn't take days off.
He just pushes it and he's always hurt is always sore.
He's always like aching,
barely can get out of bed,
has to drink coffee,
take aspirin,
hot shower and then starts running just crazy.
It's just,
it's just tough.
There's certain people,
man,
they just,
and a lot of them are hunters like we're known was one of those guys.
He's just fucking tough.
Just they have this mental toughness,
the ability to endure discomfort that the average person just doesn't get.
And I think it's accentuated by this life or death struggle that you,
you experience on a day to day basis when you're hunting,
you can kind of compartmentalize certain aches and pains and hunger and thirst
and cold.
You could just block that shit out and keep going or the average person sorta
wallows in that stuff.
But you know,
you ha you have to,
you come into this,
this,
you have to do these certain things where you're tasked with something,
it's probably a lot harder than the average person thinks you can do,
but you,
once you've done it once meant it's a lot of this stuff's mental and that's the
apex predators show that I've been doing comes back to a lot of Shit's just
mental.
Yeah.
It's so many things.
A lot is mental with almost everything.
Yeah.
With almost like,
you know,
tattoos here and it was a bad example,
but everybody says like how bad tattoos hurt.
I fell asleep and I was getting tattooed.
Like it doesn't hurt.
I mean it hurts a little,
but it's not her.
It doesn't hurt like someone kicking you in the head.
It doesn't hurt.
Like someone trying to choke your fucking neck off.
No,
it doesn't,
it doesn't hurt.
Like a lot of things hurt.
Like they really hurt.
That's this is this discomfort and there's a difference between discomfort and
real pain.
Yeah.
And what you can endure.
Like you,
a lot of times people start focusing on the discomfort and like it accentuates,
it starts,
it becomes like their entire focus becomes this pain instead of doing the task,
like blocking out whatever discomfort that you have dealing with it and get
through it right
then going on.
I sometimes that that Alaska trip it while we're doing it,
we're like,
would you do this again?
No.
And then when it's over where we were so excited,
we're just wanting to do it again.
And it was because we hurt the whole time.
Like,
when's the last time you just hurt for a week?
Just punished.
You're in.
It's,
and it's like this cool experience where you push yourself to these limits and
then you feel awesome afterwards.
Well,
after it's done,
done the middle of the toilet,
you're like,
Oh God,
this is not fun.
But you get,
Oh,
you get back to camp that night we flew in a few beers,
crack open a beer after in the middle of nowhere.
And you go,
Yep,
let's do this again.
Rinella has a whole way of describing it that he said he learned from one of his
buddies is that there's different kinds of fun.
There's the kind of fun that's fun while you're doing it,
but it's not fun later.
Right?
And there's a kind of fun that's not fun while you're doing it,
but afterwards you have amazing fun memories and it's awesome.
It's so weird.
I,
I noticed and you,
you know,
I don't know if you've,
here's this yet,
but for me,
you know,
I've hunted a lot and so I almost like to punish myself in some,
I like it to be hard.
I like to be a challenge.
So I will actually create it to be,
I just did this hunt in New Zealand where I was hunting these,
these fallow deer.
And at any given time,
for the first few days I could have shot a deer.
Well,
if hunt a lot of people don't realize as hunters,
it's not always the goal to just go shoot something.
It's part of the experience.
And so for me,
I just kept passing up animals because the experience wasn't right until the
last day when I was supposed to leave early.
And I end up,
oh,
I'm just going to be hunting for two hours and I don't bring any water.
And I ended up hunting all day and going,
I don't even know how far,
18 miles maybe.
And I didn't bring any food,
any water,
and I'm hurting.
And I ended up shooting a deer last light.
And,
and now is to me is awesome experience.
It made the trip and made that memory,
the hardship made the memory and something that I as a hunter that hunters don't
really maybe understand is like having these antlers around and when the meets
long gone,
I can look at that and remember the hardship and the journey and the adventure
and these other things about the experience and the meat was a byproduct.
But these are the memories that I like.
You look at that Moose and you think of something completely different than I,
do you remember how it went down?
You remember,
you know,
maybe the struggle or carrying the meat back or whatever.
So I may have a,
a rack in my house that's sitting up on the mantle.
And why is that one on the mantle and that one will,
that one I had to work real hard for.
So I look at it and I think it reminds me constantly of what I went through.
When you say that the experience wasn't right,
what,
what do you mean by that?
Like I feel sometimes it just wasn't a challenge.
It was,
I would have been shooting an animal,
not the,
wasn't there,
the challenge wasn't there.
It just wasn't the right time.
I wanted to keep going until it,
until it happened.
I don't know.
It's so weird.
But for me,
hunting's about the adventure and everything behind it.
And so as well as obviously getting meat,
but there comes a point where,
you know,
okay,
if I didn't get a deer this week,
well maybe I'll,
I'll get one next week.
I'm not going to starve to death.
I've got a freezer with meat.
But I also want to keep that freezer full.
But so it comes to a point for me where it's about other things as well.
The experience,
the adventure,
the meat,
all combining into this.
If it's too easy,
I just don't like it.
That's fast.
I don't know.
It'll come.
It'll happen.
You know?
For me it happened.
I started when I was younger.
I never wanted to stop hunting because I liked the experience of being out there
so much.
So I would do what a lot of people call trophy hunting.
And I'm air quoting that because it means something different to me or I would
look for a bigger deer because I wanted to keep hunting and make it more of a
challenge for myself.
I see what you're saying.
See what I'm saying.
So instead of like some people they want a bigger deer so they could say,
hey,
I got a one 90 buck and one 90 inch and look,
it's on.
You know,
and they will,
they'll measure everything and look at his tines and look how big is for you it
was just,
it's a more difficult pursuit.
Right.
Just the dif difficult pursuit where it keeps me in the field longer because if
I shoot that first,
first deer I see,
I would be the type of guy that goes out.
If I've got 10 days to hunt on 110 days,
I don't want to shoot something on the first day.
Even if I ended up getting something in the last hour,
the last day that I would have shot the first day,
I don't want to spend those 10 days out hunting.
That's funny.
I'm the opposite.
I'll shoot that fucker in the first minute first.
I would love to set the account up,
turned around,
look,
look what I got.
Boom,
cut it up,
start eating it on the spot.
But I've,
I haven't been hunting as long.
I think when you've been hunting,
as long as you have also,
you kind of appreciate what you appreciate after the fact.
Like you,
you have a real deep understanding of what it means to you.
Whereas to me it's all pretty new.
Yeah.
I've only been doing it for three,
not even three years now.
So it's like,
oh,
crazy.
We're shooting a Turkey now.
Oh this is cool.
Like,
oh,
we're going to go shoot this and I want to eat that and it's fun.
I enjoy it.
I love the Turkey.
I don't know if I'll do that again.
I might,
I mean it's not that I didn't like it,
but what I didn't like about the Turkey,
as you work all day and you know,
several days in a row to get a Turkey and you can only,
it's like a meal,
a meal for my family.
They couldn't even eat the whole Turkey,
let's like,
it's not that big,
you know.
So in Nevada checker hunting's big and you might Work Yorker chucker what's it's
a,
it's a partridge.
Ah,
it looks,
they're from the Middle East.
They aren't native,
but they be released into the mountain and they're always,
they live in cliffs and there is a really animal to hunt
and you may go out and only shoot one bird and hike.
My friend put his little track,
my run thing on and we're hiking,
like we hit back to the truck after Chickering like,
you know,
I'm pretty tired.
It's like 22 miles because you're walking from sunup to sundown and steep.
But,
and it's like,
well we got one bird between the three of us.
It's just,
it's where I grew up.
That was the thing to do.
But it's not even lunch.
No,
but it's more,
you're out there,
you're working hard for it.
So if you get it and when you get,
when you shoot six of them,
then you,
you really feel like you've accomplished something.
Well,
how much is one like as far as the amount of meat you get out of one,
like to quail.
Wow.
Yeah.
So like six ounces.
Eight ounces maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe not even.
Not even.
Wow.
Fuck that.
But I know,
but when it's just the pursuit of it as well.
So you get,
you get into and then the,
and then the more you fail,
the the harder you want to try to succeed.
So the next time you go out you want to go further and harder and try to get,
shoot better.
I Dunno.
That's interesting.
So it becomes,
so hunting isn't just about going out and acquiring meat.
Hunting is also about the challenge of the pursuit of the animal being being the
hunter,
being the Predator out there,
trying to outsmart or out hunt,
defy their natural instincts,
figure out how to avoid the wind blowing in their nose.
Figuring out how to approach them the right way and to make it even more
difficult.
Going after the bigger ones that are smarter than I've been alive longer and
making it a more difficult task and making the appreciation of the
accomplishment much better.
Yeah,
and the harder something is,
the more skill you need,
the more you've honed your abilities in the end.
And I've always said the harder you worked for something better it tastes.
If you asked me what the best tasting thing is,
l just because you work hard for elk now,
Himalayan Tar and New Zealand,
I think they're delicious.
It's a goat that lives in the mountains,
but you work your ass off for it and when you sit down to eat it,
you appreciate it.
It's just a different feeling.
What does it taste like?
Because goat,
a lot of people don't like it.
Tastes like venison.
Really.
It's kind of good.
It's kind of got marbled fat in the meat,
which is different.
Mountain mountain goods have that as well.
They have a while coat.
Yeah.
To pull up an image of a Himalayan tar icon there.
Gorilla grizzly be HR,
I think EHR.
Yes.
Or G H J or either way.
That's a wild looking animal.
Yeah.
Cool.
That was like a Werewolf Chewbacca or something like that,
and I like their back looks like a grizzly or a gorilla because they've got
these silver stripes down the back and then they've got a lion's mane on the
front and then I look at that thing.
I'm like,
fuck,
what a wild,
they're probably one of my favorite,
favorite stat is so strange and that's a very difficult hunt.
Right?
Can Be.
It depends how you want to do it.
Now it's like for me,
I want to walk up from the bottom,
but you could take a helicopter to the top.
We'll do that.
Oh yeah.
In New Zealand.
Yeah.
Really?
Look at that fucking face.
That looks like a baboon's or something crazy wild looking half lion and they
have a red meat.
That's just like venison.
Yeah.
Wow.
Now some people,
they fly up on a helicopter,
they shoot these things and then they what?
Fly back down now like what are the elevations you're climbing when you're
dealing with these things?
Four thousand five thousand feet maybe.
Wow.
It depends where you're at.
Three to five,
three to six.
And it's all weird,
rocky,
slippery terrain.
Very precarious.
I watched one of your episodes of solo hunter when you went after these things.
Oh yeah.
Was it,
when did I get one or did I fail one?
You didn't get one.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You Go,
I mean,
just the,
the adventure and getting up there is half the fun in the first place.
What the fuck is that pounding?
Is that next door doing demo demo where you're building a robot?
Um,
yeah.
It seems like those,
um,
those,
those trips are very strange too because you were staying in one of those weird
cabins that they have set up there for people that can just,
they can just use them anytime they want.
They can go up there and hang out in those cabins.
Hopefully cuts.
Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
Is it that many people that go hunting up there?
They have,
those things are there for,
oh,
they're here.
Not An earring.
A lot of it's,
most of the ones I stand her for ice climbing because I liked hunting around the
glaciers.
So they're all,
uh,
ice climber huts.
Like are you based out of before you go really nice climbing.
Well that's a really popular pursuit around there.
No,
but there's so much so that they have huts.
Yeah,
because,
well yeah,
because it's tough terrain and if that's your sport,
these groups like build these huts.
There's historical significance to some of them too.
They're put in for cooling expeditions back when animals are running rampant
there because they're all non natives.
Is it completely talking about,
I like to talk about New Zealand because it's a place that I've,
I've come to love for a lot of reasons,
but when you talk about conservation,
there is completely different than we think of it here.
It's almost a,
it's a different world and it's really hard to explain to people that don't
understand it because the animals aren't technically supposed to be there,
but we want them there and they can't get rid of them.
So there's a completely different system in place there.
They don't have any tags.
You don't have to have a license,
you just go.
Not yet.
Well,
you have to have this thing you get online for free,
but things might change.
Who knows it as it is right now.
Yeah.
You just open.
Is there a some movement to try to change it and regulated?
I think it looks like there might be not necessarily just not that they want
less animal shot because a lot of people there would want them all gone if they
could.
I mean they poison animals.
The government shoots him out of helicopters.
Yeah,
they have to.
Cause there's so many no predators and no one,
no knuckle heads want to bring wolves over there.
Anything,
uh,
back in,
back during,
I think it was World War II,
they'd proposed to bring mountain lions.
Well,
it's the,
it's the woman who swallowed a fly problem like swallow and why?
So I'm going to swallow a frog.
What they,
what they found out is,
so they bring in rabbits and then they bring in ferrets to kill the rabbits and
weasels.
And then they find out that the Robinson,
the ferrets are in killing these endangered flightless birds because they're
like,
he's here to kill.
And her were having,
and so the non natives eat the native plants and kill off the native wildlife.
Did you find that,
did you read that study?
They did recently on deer and deer eating birds now and that it's incredibly
common for deer to eat birds and that not only will deer eat birds,
they'll find nesting birds and they'll eat them.
They'll find ground nesting birds,
delete chicks.
But they also found,
they did,
they had these birds that were caught in a net and much to their surprise,
mature deer were walking up to these birds that were caught in the net and just
eating him alive.
And that birds apparently are on the,
on the menu for deer.
Deer.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
No one knew,
but this is really,
really recent discovery.
Oh,
I wonder if w where's there more Buchser dose or do they even know?
Just,
I don't know,
Jamie Cvo pull up that article.
The,
because all you got it already dear.
I've been eating birds for years.
They do need a lower protein,
especially the females need it when they're
uh,
pregnant,
and then the males need it.
When they're growing their handlers,
they,
they pick out higher protein grass and other things.
It makes sense that if they eat a bird,
then they get a little bit more protein in their diet.
They're eating the heads and legs of live seabird chicks as a way to get
minerals they need to grow their antlers.
Scientists believe that surprising addition to the red deer's diets stems from
mineral deficiencies and the vegetation they eat.
Wow.
There's a bunch of different versions of this that they've,
uh,
there's more than one study that they've sort of a,
this is from 2003.
This is not the one.
There's one firm much more recent.
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
Field cameras.
Huh?
Yeah.
This is,
this is the most recent one.
This is the North American one.
It's crazy.
In North Dakota,
they set up nest cams over a ness of songbirds expected to see.
So a lot of the nestlings and eggs getting eaten by ground squirrels,
foxes and badgers.
Squirrels hit 13 nasty other meat eaters made a poor showing foxes and weasels
only took one nest each.
You know what fearsome animal out did either of those two sleek,
resourceful predators.
White tail deer,
the eight living nestlings right out of the nests and if you're thinking that
must be a mistake that the deer were chewing the way through.
Some vegetation happened upon a mouthful.
Bird think again.
Up in Canada,
a group of Ortho knowledgist.
It's nice money on a theologist.
We're studying adult birds in order to examine them closely.
Researchers used mist nets.
These nets usually draped between trees are designed to trap birds or bats
gently so that they can be collected,
studied and released.
When a herd of deer came by,
the deer walked up to the struggling birds and ate them alive right out of the
nets.
Crazy.
Oh,
that's cool.
It is wild,
man.
Huh?
A cow.
They found a cow eating a recently hatch chick.
Wow.
Herbivores eat meat when they're not getting enough nutrients in their diet.
That's interesting.
It is.
No,
it is really fascinating.
I wonder I,
it's amazing.
I wonder what other animals do things that we don't even know about.
You just happened upon it accidentally.
I'm sure there's a lot.
Yeah,
I'm sure you know,
I mean it's one of the things that they've found over the last,
uh,
I don't know how many years is how many bears eat baby bears and that it's not
just a matter of like trying to keep their blood line or trying to discourage up
and coming males,
they just eat babies.
Like that's just their Fein source.
Like when they get out of the high or the,
um,
when the,
the den,
when they're done hibernating,
they like immediately seek out cubs.
That's like one of their favorite things to eat.
I've heard that.
I wonder,
I've heard also heard that they do that for breeding reasons as well because in
the female was cycle again,
right?
Yeah.
There's all sorts of speculation about that.
But we,
uh,
when we were in a Alberta last year,
one of the guys we were with,
they had seen a female eat its own baby.
Wow.
It's really fucked.
The male had killed it and then the female finished it off.
The mail came in and tried to attack the female and tact or cop.
Her cops started eating her calm.
She chased him off and then she finished it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's my snack.
That's harsh.
That's fucking harsh,
man.
Mom,
why are you eating me?
It's not a me anymore dead.
It's a harsh fucking world.
The world of
doing the,
the APEC spreaders show,
one of the things that really kind of was surprised cause we,
you know,
start out doing a TV thing and you have these ideas of what should happen and
that never fricking happens ever.
Things always go wrong or,
or something.
But that's why I wanted to take and look at it as a learning experience.
Not necessarily come out with these pre I preconceived ideas of what's going to
happen.
I just want to act as this animal in the wild,
learn from it and then see what its life would be like.
And one of the things that I've come to the conclusion of is a lot of these
animals that we see as being super efficient and uh,
they've easily surviving.
It's a hard knock life for them.
It's not as easy.
A lot of animals scrounge and are hunting all day,
every day into the night just to get enough food to sustain themselves.
And then there's other animals that it is easier.
But for the most part I've learned that these animals that hunt daily,
it's not as easy as you might think.
You always see the highlight reel of the lion catching the gazelle,
but it's pretty hard even for the lion to catch the gazelle.
It's a,
it's a pretty interesting thought.
And then we go out as humans and it's a lot essentially,
it's a lot easier for us to hunt and catch things than it is for these.
These natural predators are animals.
Well,
I can imagine we have guns.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well that's the archery thing too,
right?
That's one of the reasons why people enjoy archery.
It's cause it is a much more difficult challenge.
You have to figure out how to get between,
you know,
20 and 50 yards proximity and yeah,
the,
the Cha,
it's,
it just goes back to that challenge of what makes it hard and,
and why you do what.
I mean there's people that only bow hunt.
There's people that bow hunt and rifle hunt.
There's people that don't traditional bow hunt and it's all based on the
challenge and the experience for them as well as a lot of ideals as far as,
okay,
well I'm a bow hunter and if you shoot with a gun that's too easy for me.
But for me I,
I do whatever kind of hunting because I just love hunting.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that have,
there's like a purity involved in like shooting something with a bow because
it's much more difficult than shooting something with a rifle.
See and I'm,
I'm cool with that,
but I sometimes for me it's,
there's hunter,
I don't like when hunters are against hunter.
If you're a hunter cause your shoot it with a rifle and then we'll the
traditional dudes like you aren't a hunter because you shoot it with a compound
bow and there's a guy out,
there were no shoes going.
You guys need to grab them with your hands and there are some other games like
you got to catch him with your teeth.
Can't we all just get along?
Yeah.
It's already a much aligned community.
I ran into uh,
Jim Shockey at this thing and,
and he's always been a hero of mine.
I was talking to him about because he came on your podcast and I listened to
that and I thought that was an awesome,
awesome podcasts.
The guy so well spoken and I love that day you can talk about anything and
you're just like,
oh wow.
It makes sense to me now.
But yeah,
I,
I was kind of talking to them about a few things and it's,
and it's in fewer words,
you just don't fuck it up,
you know,
like don't be against hunters.
And then in a thought.
Yeah,
I mean that makes sense because really it's all hunting.
We've all got the same desire to go out and harvest our meat and hunt and be out
in the wild.
What's it matter if you're doing it with a bow or on public land or private land
or with a spear?
With a gun.
I mean it's all the end result's the same as the dead animal.
Well he tried to make it more difficult for himself to make
the challenge.
So his challenge is used as muzzleloaders right?
All the time.
Yeah.
Even in regular rifle sees and uses a muzzle loader cause he only gets one shot.
Exactly.
And that that's for me it may,
if I'm hunting with a rifle then I may try to find something that's bigger or
packing to an area that's further or who knows what I do just to make it more of
a chat.
And then there's some times where obviously the only intention is I'm looking
for meat and I need that meat now.
But for the most part,
yeah you either way,
you're still out there hunting.
What brings me back to your buffalo show.
Cause the buffalo show was a particularly trying one for you because you snuck
up on this buffalo,
you got it.
It was a good shot with your bow.
But the buffalo was still alive.
They're so fucking tough and they're so big
and you know,
there's a lot of things that I would have done different,
but also I couldn't have done different in them.
Sometimes you,
you have to do what happens in that moment and make a decision.
And for me,
I didn't want to shoot a buffalo bedded down,
bison bedded down.
But some things went wrong during the filming of the camera.
Guy was in the wrong place.
And if that Bison got up and started walking off,
we wouldn't be able to film it.
And,
and so I,
I made the decision to shoot it with my bow in that particular instance.
And I had to live with that decision and yeah,
I shot it where it would have been good,
but it just,
the boat didn't penetrate hard enough and it was nothing.
I mean,
the equipment was all right,
everything was right.
It was just one of those deals where a quarter inch left or right and maybe
would have made a difference.
It hit the shoulder and just,
yeah,
the next day it was still alive.
And for me,
I mean there's guys that could maybe watch that episode and go,
well your bow hunting and you shot it in the end with if you haven't seen him
given away a spoiler alert.
But yeah,
and I ended up shooting it with a rifle the next day.
And for me it,
it wasn't about bow hunting or rifle hunting or being a purist in this former or
following through because of the,
the natives who did that tactic would have only used primitive weaponry or order
for me in that moment is about putting that bison down and you know,
it's,
as hunters,
we don't want to see an animal suffer this,
that,
or the other thing.
So it didn't really matter what I shot it with in the end,
I just wanted to do my job to,
to make things right.
Right.
That had to be a hard feeling to,
to know that this animal's wounded and you have to go to sleep.
I didn't even sleep that night and there it was raining.
We,
I think we got back to the tents at
one 30 in the morning.
Later it had been just dumping rain.
We lost the blood trail and it just,
you know,
we're just an,
I also didn't want to keep pushing it because at some point you think,
okay,
well you,
it's not smart to track at night.
The only reason we were tracking it at night was because the rain was coming and
then it just,
there was good blood and then we lost the blood trail and decided to come back
the next day.
And,
and luckily things turned out.
But I,
when I came away from that trip,
there's a lot of things that I was like,
you know,
but I,
I,
when I do a television show,
I like to make things.
I don't necessarily need to show people that I'm pounding my chest and be the
greatest dog,
show my failures as well.
And not saying that that was a failure or whatever,
but you know,
even in Solo hunters or other things,
there's a lot episodes where I don't get anything and there's a lot of hunting
shows that won't show that.
But for me it's a real,
it's hunting and I've missed things with my bow and miss things with my rifle,
I've messed up.
But you know,
I keep doing it and I think,
you know,
if,
if I just edited things,
how I'm always,
it's always perfect,
then I'm just kind of lying to myself really
there.
I think if there was very few hunting shows out there,
maybe that would be acceptable.
I'd like to try to make it like the most exciting version of hunting possible.
But I think it's really important to portray it for what it really is.
Yeah.
Would,
it really is,
is a difficult pursuit even for an expert hundred like yourself.
It doesn't always work.
No.
Things go wrong and,
and you know,
and then,
and then it also has the gravity of the situation.
You know,
we come upon a bison and shoot it with a rifle and the bison drops.
And uh,
that episode in particular,
um,
I had quite a few people that weren't hunters at all,
but it started watching the series and they said that it was like there was no
warning the bison just died.
And they,
they were like,
I felt sad.
And I said,
yeah,
that's the point.
Like you go through the,
you felt the emotions of a hunter.
I don't necessarily feel sad,
but I talk about it in the end.
I say that the path of a hunter is a humbling path and it really is like in that
moment you watch that and go,
boom,
this bison just is now dead.
And you go,
Whoa,
Eagle.
Right?
And then there's also the feeling of I'm thankful for this bison and now it's
providing me with all this meat.
And that is what it is to be a hunter.
You go through a range of emotions no matter how many times you've done it,
that,
yeah,
life begets life.
And now,
now this bison is no longer an animal is a source of meat and I'm going to use
that throughout the year.
That's the real big difference between someone who's been involved in the taking
of the life,
whether you're a farmer and the kills your own cows or whether you're a hunter
that goes out and hunts the meat.
There's a,
there's a much deeper understanding of what you're actually eating.
Yeah.
I don't think it's necessarily healthy that we could just go to a supermarket
and buy a steak.
I just,
I think it's weird.
It just gives you a massive disconnect and that's where all the self
righteousness from people wearing leather,
eating meat and getting angry at people for hunting.
That's where it all comes from.
It's like it's,
it's a sickness.
It's like a,
there's a disconnect,
like a complete total disconnect from what you're doing by eating a hamburger.
You're how you hired a supermarket,
hit man to go out there and kill those fucking animals and package it up so you
can be completely insulated from the life or death struggle.
And then you're getting at other people,
like the idea of a meat eating person who wears leather.
Being upset at hunting is one of the great,
bizarre hypocrisy of our culture.
Yeah.
It doesn't really make sense.
And I,
I can't,
for me,
I've seen,
you know,
I have a respect for my food in a different way that someone,
an animal is now,
food is not an animal.
But for me,
meat is always an animal.
It's always food.
I,
I respect it in that way.
And when it becomes meat than it,
it becomes something different to me.
But it's still an animal.
I think it's kind of a weird story.
But they had a horse that,
uh,
we'd use the pack out things and whatever in it and it breaking it to like,
and,
uh,
we had to shoot it.
Okay.
And so I didn't want to do it because he is like,
you have this attachment to this animal.
And then,
uh,
my other guy didn't want to do it either,
but one of the guys that hadn't used the horses,
we talked to him.
Okay.
Like you need to put this horse down.
He shot the horse.
And I still felt like,
okay,
this is like,
now we have a dental.
And so I don't know why,
but I cut the back stakes out and ate the horse.
There's like,
people are going to be like,
that is discussed,
that is sick.
But for me it was like,
okay,
well now it serves the utility a purpose.
It's now food.
It's no longer wasted.
Yeah.
Otherwise you'd be wasting it.
Something's going to eat it.
Either bacteria is going to eat it or predators or rodents or scavengers.
Someone's going to eat it.
Yeah.
Why shouldn't you?
And I've had horse before.
I had it in Montreal.
It was a place called Joe beef.
They,
I've had horse tar tar or I've had raw horse and I've had a horse,
a loins with a,
they cooked like the back strap and they cooked.
Uh,
they,
they cooked it up like a steak.
It was delicious.
Yeah.
So really it's been there.
You know,
in the end it's meat and now in smoke,
but I mean obviously you like it is pat what?
Oh,
Sicko.
But yeah,
for me it was more out of a respect thing.
Okay.
Now it's the circle of life.
Some people will knock an understand that now it's weird,
but that's okay.
There's,
you can't help everybody understand things that make sense to me.
It's,
to me it's makes sense because it's good meat.
It's healthy for you.
It's very common.
Eaton,
Europe,
it's one of the weird things is I've,
I believe a lot of the horse they buy in Canada comes from the United States,
but we can't sell it in the United States.
Yeah,
I know.
I had an Iceland and those horses are,
that was the only other time I'd had it.
I couldn't remember.
Part of the reasons I was like,
you can't actually get horse here.
I might as well
try it.
Yeah.
We served horse rectum on fear factor once and it was,
yeah,
people are just so angry.
I believe it was boiled.
I was very chewy and disgusting,
but people were so angry and it was a horse.
Yeah,
it's a horse
to a lot of folks.
It's like if we started serving dog tongue,
people would be like,
you assholes.
You sort of serving dog town.
That's our pet,
you know?
So for a lot of people,
their horses even more intimately involved in their life.
Then a dog,
because they ride it like that horse worked.
It carried.
It was like it carried elk for me,
it was on the hunt,
which is kind of a weird,
I mean maybe it was,
yeah,
it's a weird philosophy.
I mean it's an animal that you associate with and it's weird,
but I think it's,
I think what you [inaudible] I was like,
I didn't really know.
I felt weird about it and then I was like,
but then when we cooked it up and it became,
it was like,
okay,
yeah,
it's,
I don't know.
I'm glad I did it.
I don't know if I'd do it again,
but I thought in that moment it felt right.
How much of the meat did you take off the horse?
The back strap.
That's it.
Yeah.
Because,
well,
it was pretty,
yeah,
and I thought,
well there was other animals out there that we're also going to eat it,
but it would've been,
it would've been impossible to get an arrest out.
When you were,
where you were in a bare area where the arrows,
yeah,
the berries ate it within,
it was gone.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I went back.
How long?
I went back like three days later.
It was pretty much toast.
Wow.
Yeah.
What kind of bears?
Black bears are groups.
Eagles were,
they eat a lot.
There's just probably when I got there,
I don't,
there was a lot eagles on it.
That's crazy.
Eagles eat a lot.
I'm sure.
I know how.
Yeah,
there's maybe a combination of animals,
coyotes,
eagles,
bears.
Amazing how quick nature can eat something like that.
A horse and it was a horror thousand pounds or something.
Probably even more big ass animal gets devoured in a few days.
A few days it's gone.
Yeah.
That's why when people say,
talk about like finding dead animals in the woods,
like you've rarely you'll find bones.
Yeah.
You know and whole animals.
Very rarely try finding a dead mountain lion.
Good luck.
And you live your whole life.
Never,
never see a dead mountain.
While I've only found one really dead one.
Where was it?
In a river.
Ooh,
it's round.
Yup.
Well I think a high water.
Either it's trade swimming across or something.
Have you ever seen that picture of a mountain lion and a mountain goat that
apparently got into a scrap and they both fell off the mountain onto a highway
and there was dead?
Was it a sheep or a goat?
Maybe it was a big horn sheep.
Now that I'm thinking about,
I think you're right.
I did see a picture or something like that.
A whole series of pictures.
Is there a pictures of him actually fighting like,
oh,
they're dead.
They're both there they are.
Bam.
They're both dead on the road.
Huh?
It's a crazy picture.
I think that thing to the left is one of the horns.
Yeah.
Well what happened?
Because the w when they fall along with these air pressure blows through and
pops the horn off.
We're really look at it.
Look at the top would go up a little bit of blew that horn.
Like where?
Where it came off
this weird bloody stump with a horn popped off and then it fell off a cliff or
got hit by a,
we'll go down to,
no,
it died off the cliff.
Look,
he's got a mouthful of far.
He died with a mouthful of further fucking monster.
Look at.
He's got it in his mouth as he's dead.
That's crazy.
Oh well we're a broken legs and shit.
Look at the fall
fun.
Hmm.
That's crazy.
Imagine stumbling upon.
That is a cool thing to see.
Candida.
I Dunno.
But it's a classic glacier national park or is that at that same Montana?
Wow.
That's amazing.
It's so cool.
Stumbling upon things like that.
Just seeing,
just seeing the,
well you,
especially having seen wolves actually take out and elk.
Oh yeah.
It's pretty cool.
So what different animals?
Emily,
I know this week is wolf.
Yes.
And this week,
so the first episode we did the alligator,
it's trying to grab pig.
Did you?
I didn't have seen that.
Oh yeah,
that's,
that's fine.
So the first episode we,
I emulated the alligator learned from the alligator and my goal was to learn
from the alligator,
but I was trying to grab a wild boar bare handed and you got to watch that
episode.
It's pretty cool.
That sounds like the most ridiculous idea.
Or what about the tusks?
You worry about reaching back and biting you.
I wasn't until I was about four feet away.
Did you tell me,
cause that's going to drive people to the site.
Okay.
Apex,
Predator.
Dot.
TV Apex.
Predator dot.
TV.
If they go there,
they can actually stream the entire season,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
The ones that haven't aired yet or no.
So what happens?
You can,
if you get,
if you buy the season,
the day they air,
when the air live on TV,
you also get access to it online.
Oh,
okay.
So so every Thursday at 8:00 PM east or it probably,
I think it's right after shorter 8:30 PM east boom in play the trailer,
Jamie,
let's play the trailer
dump.
Dump,
dump,
dump in the wild.
Every animal has adapted to survive
as humans.
We have learned from those adaptations to become better hunters were the
planet's top frame,
but we didn't get here alone.
Nature itself was team.
I'm Remy Ma.
I'm going to study animals in their environments and learn what makes them
successful and challenge myself with nearly impossible hunt giving you raw
skills only obtained from experience.
I plan to immerse myself in nature and hunt like an
that's a cool fucking trailer dude.
He has great.
Those guys at 0.0 they know what they're doing so good.
The thing about it is when we started doing it,
I mean I hate corny things and every time we'd think of an episode we go,
this could either be the cornice dumbest thing ever or it could be amazing and
the fact that we can take something and be real about it and not have to create
drama and other things and make it educational where you can still learn and do
something that nobody else has really tried and and make it not ridiculous to me
is a win.
Well,
I also doing it on the sportsmans channel.
You could actually do the whole show,
right?
You could actually do it the way you want to do it.
They're not going to fuck with you.
Where if you were doing this on,
you know,
fill in the blank and name another cable channel,
they would give you a hard time.
They just,
they're not used to hunting.
They would try to turn it into some bullshit reality show and predetermined
endings.
They would try to predetermined beats in it to make sure they kept,
people know there's an offer.
That first step,
that alligator episode we,
I got charged by a peg when I'm moving locations and grab it and tackle it.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause we were just,
I was just bare handing everything and I left it out of the episode because for
two reasons,
one,
Dan was filming,
he was on the other side of a Bush and so he just,
he didn't actually get that charge on film.
But the other part was I caught it in a way that wasn't about the learning
aspect of
the alligator.
Right.
So it was just an incidental,
it just happened.
I just got charged cackled this pig.
How did you tackle it?
And I had grabbed it,
pine,
the neck,
and then threw it down,
grabbed his bag.
Pig wasn't very big as luckily a hundred pounds,
50 pounds.
Um,
I don't even know.
75 pounds.
50 pounds.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Small,
big middle.
Yeah.
Somewhere in there.
So it charged you that mouth of and racks.
And the thing was honoree.
Yeah,
we put up an ear.
You can see that they get,
we put it on our youtube channel.
Oh,
you can see the video?
Yeah,
we,
I put that on the youtube channel,
but we didn't to,
what's the Youtube Channel?
Apex Predator or apex?
Predator TV.
Apex.
Predator TV or I dunno.
So or on our,
yeah,
me.
We're on our social media.
There's only code and the pig.
So why did they charge you?
They're,
you're just,
I don't know.
I just had about government and just fuckers.
Yeah.
I think that pig charged me.
I think that pig had been caught by human before.
Like dogs recently.
I think it had been let go again.
Oh by dog.
Yeah.
Cause it,
it looked like it had been,
so I think it was just already pissed off.
Enough is enough.
You fucks.
That's what he was like.
Yeah.
But you know,
I think pigs,
we'll do that from time to time.
They just kind of won't charge if they feel like it was funny because
that's where we recreate something.
As you notice,
there's Dan,
this is the recreation.
Uh Oh,
you grab a wild boar.
That's it.
Everything's a board by the way.
Even if it's a female,
ever noticed that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
A wild pig at the store,
but you can't get a wild boar.
It's a weird way,
you know,
it's kind of stupid.
It just a little bit little guy.
Luckily
that thing charged you.
It was funny as laying in a wall and just straight up.
It just looks at me and there was no lag time.
Just Bam on me like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's probably a pig that had been fucked with.
So what'd you guys wind up doing with them?
Go,
but I tied it up with,
uh,
I had some p cord because the whole goal was I was trying to grab the Bor.
I wasn't going to kill him
and or a peg.
It could've been if you sow to
strolling around in my head above water using endangers thing,
this thing instantly charged me.
I mean there wasn't even a split second and wheeled around and came right at me.
So wait,
wait,
what did it try to bite?
They try to bite your leg a gate or anything.
It's just had mouth opening comment and you just jumped down on,
it's back of it's neck cause they pick camp bite its own button.
So if you get both of its back legs can't bite shit.
But it's Kinda hard to get both their back legs.
I ended up just kind of getting its back legs,
getting behind it and then throwing it down,
putting a knee on it and then tying it hog tying it.
Wow.
When you let them go,
no,
you're really fucking let it go.
And it was uh,
we ended up having to go to,
there was a tree.
There was,
luckily there was like a tree stand nearby and so Dan gets up from the tree
standing on my all into it.
Sorry.
I think it's hanging around the tree going,
I had to climb up the tree stand and we let it go.
Wow.
What a gangster.
A little pit.
It was Henri and then just strolls off like I showed those guys.
Wow.
That's pretty cool.
Have you ever been charged by anything else in the wild?
Not Seriously,
no.
I mean nothing that um,
nothing life threatening really.
I would say.
I mean I've had l like wounded elk come pretty close then getting at me,
but that was just because somebody messed up and it wasn't a,
it was pretty weird.
They were just trying to figure out a way to get out of there if they have to
put their head down and run at you antlers first.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it wasn't like a chart.
It was different.
Yeah.
Antlers.
The fucking antlers on elk are insane.
How nature engineered an elk that they fall off and grow back every year.
Imagine really quick,
if you could harness that growing potential.
I think that's why,
that's why they put staghorn and a lot of performance enhancing things cause the
magic powers.
Well,
velvet,
a deer antler spray is a human growth hormone enhancer.
Right.
I don't know if it works,
but I know that a lot of people were getting into that.
Like a lot of football players
supposedly now you can't even,
it's illegal to use in the NFL.
Not illegal to use,
but like in the NFL.
Right.
Well,
I was so good.
Yeah,
I think so.
I,
that's what I was guiding a guy that plays for the,
in the NFL a couple,
few weeks ago,
a month ago,
and uh,
he was like,
yeah,
we can't use the stag horn.
That's hilarious.
And steroids,
they have a weird though,
the whole relationship that football has to steroids.
Is it similar way,
the what the UFC has to steroids,
but the UFC is more aggressively pursuing it.
I think the,
uh,
the NFL,
if you look at football players from the 1960s and you look at football players
for 2015,
you're like,
okay,
what the fuck happened?
What happened?
Did,
did humans evolve to humans become much larger?
Like what happened?
Well,
there's certainly like advancements in strength and conditioning programs,
understanding recovery and how to enhance growth and all these different things,
but there's also steroids.
No goddamn down about it.
Supplements do make a big difference.
Oh,
I know.
It's,
you know,
anything.
Even vitamins and things.
Oh yeah,
there you go.
But yeah.
Well the size,
these fuckers,
they used to be one 90 now the three 35.
Oh my God.
Different game though as well.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
I mean,
the,
the guy on the 1927 is not wearing a hell
64 or 67 like I was still two 45 and 1967 that guy was unnatural toot Alan Page
and natural to 45 big dude.
Yeah.
That's a big fucker.
And that's a,
that's a real two 45 whereas this guy from 2006,
335 pounds,
these guys are,
these guys are in phenomenal shape though.
The guy that I took out,
his name was Justin Tuck and uh,
he's a big dude,
but just strong.
Oh yeah.
Naturally,
I wouldn't want to stand in a line against the guy rip you in half
Nicholas Job Raisie running at each other,
giant dudes running at each other.
Why it explained it.
He's like,
yeah,
it's just like getting a car wreck daily for your job.
Just running into another guy that's just as big.
Well,
they're starting to realize now the overall effect of all these car wrecks and
it's not pretty.
And it's interesting because there's this class action lawsuit against the NFL
and there's all these different people that are saying they're going to start
suing and all these different players that played for years and years and years
that are now debilitated.
They're just,
their brains have come to toast.
Did you see the real sports a piece on it?
They did.
No,
I didn't.
It's scary.
It's terrifying because they have all sorts of like very predictable patterns
that these guys follow when they have traumatic brain injury,
impulsiveness,
violent outbursts,
uh,
memory loss.
And they essentially become a totally different human being.
And it's all because their brain is,
and the,
the,
the damage takes really 10 years to fully manifest.
So if they get a massive concussion,
the real damage is like 10 years down the line.
It's insidious.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I imagine it probably goes for any full contact sport.
Like MMA is a real issue.
The real issue in MMA for sure guys are starting to talk about it now about how
to mitigate it by not sparring is hard.
Um,
trying to um,
spar less and concentrate more on strength conditioning drills,
the drills skill,
skill based drills for fighting.
Cause in the old days and some,
some camps still do it this way.
They would just go to war three,
four days a week.
They would just glove up and beat the fuck out of each other and that's how they
got better.
And that's how they learned.
And there's,
there's some,
there's some benefit to that,
you know,
me becomes normal to you.
Yeah.
You know,
much like when we were talking about earlier about the mental aspect of just
being tough enough to deal with certain situations and not,
you know,
not freaking out and not being overwhelmed by your,
your,
your thoughts.
Like,
Oh my God,
I'm suffering.
Yeah,
that's,
that's similar in martial arts too.
Like one of the sayings in Jujitsu is always you got to get comfortable with
being uncomfortable because Jujitsu,
like sometimes people panic tap,
they just get in a bad situation,
it just hurts and they just can't take it.
And they tap where they really don't have to tap.
It's just pain.
It's do not in danger of getting an arm broken.
You're not in danger of being put to sleep.
You're just,
you're just in pain.
So you've got to just deal with that and just recognize it's only a sensation.
And I imagine too,
once you get to a certain threshold,
you know,
I handled this last time and I think that happened.
Yup.
And then you can keep moving on.
You can,
but there's also borders.
There's like borders when it comes to joints.
Like there's some things you shouldn't fight off because like you have to
realize as you get older,
especially you realize,
okay,
um,
the reason why I don't want to tap here is because of my ego.
But if I do tap,
then I don't have to go to the hospital and get surgery on my fucking elbow.
Yeah.
But if I don't tap,
I'm going to get my elbow ripped apart and then they're going to have to
reconstruct it because I've already done this before.
Sorry.
I'll just tap.
All right and then you're fine.
You're good.
That's the cool thing about Jujitsu is you can just tap most of the time that's
the case.
There's occasional injuries but there'll be occasional injuries if you do any
kind of sport where you're trying really hard to do something.
We even tag football.
There's,
there's hardcore injuries with tag football.
I read somewhere that most the highest rate of sports injuries from running
soccer's a big one.
ACL,
ACL reconstructions for soccer.
It's like one
of the biggest uh,
methods or reasons why people tear their ligaments,
their knees,
they're like throw a kick.
They're planted and they did,
they kick and their foot doesn't move and their body torques and it's taught
pop.
Yet those guys are,
that's one of those things.
They're in pretty good shape.
I mean cause you're running is a sport we were running with it.
What I started doing was I got like a sock.
I'm not very good at soccer or whatever,
but running up and down hills with a soccer ball,
like juggling it cause then you get,
you like got to control the ball.
So on your decent and things you're,
you're actually working a lot harder.
So that's what you do for training and just started that.
So even on the decent you have to control the ball.
Would you have rather than out of it or something?
Yeah.
Or just like try to control it.
Like slow it down because then otherwise you chasing a ball even though you hunt
like you probably like what,
300 days a year or something crazy like that.
Yeah,
it's been a little bit less not,
I've been doing more TV things and other stuff,
but yeah.
Even though all of that you still have to train for hunting.
Yeah,
I just,
yeah,
that's a new,
you have to,
that's a big one that I think there's a massive misconception in the public
side.
They think of hunters as being these fat guys who drink beer and go out and
shoot animals and laugh about it.
They don't realize like there's guys like you,
like you were talking about this the last time you were here,
you have this insane vo two Max and then when they studied you for that Predator
show for your Predator shores to they um,
they tested your vo two Max and you'll like in like some elite endurance athlete
territory.
And that is crazy because it's essentially,
I haven't trained for that,
but it's just by hunting.
I am training for that.
It is an endurance sport.
You're out there every day grinding and up and down mountains and
working hard.
It's a,
it's a hard now.
I mean if you're sitting in a tree stand all the time,
it's different.
Right.
But hunting to me is something different than maybe someone else.
Something.
Well that was one of the fun episodes of Solo Hunter was you up in a tree stand
hunting deer and you'd like to Sox,
I hate this.
I'm way to add for this.
Well that's with doing the Apex Predator.
I've realized my biggest mental thing is patience.
I have happy I can.
I'll hike all day every day for years.
Doesn't matter.
I love it,
but tell me to sit down for an hour like I go crazy.
I would not do well in prison.
He probably just get your,
you're probably designed like of all these years of pursuing spot and stalk
hunting and going after elk especially.
That's your specialty,
right?
It's elk.
L had so much mountain climbing.
It's so much hiking up hills and people don't realize how difficult that is if
you don't do it,
especially if you don't do it with a rifle,
a pack on your back,
you don't realize how God damn heavy everything is.
Your lungs are would give out.
Exactly.
Like my,
my legs were fine.
Like the first trip I ever did in Montana,
we went to the,
there was all this up and down and that real slippery shake.
My legs were fine,
but my lungs were like,
fuck dude.
He could have,
you could have
prepared us for this.
I was like,
I didn't know.
I had no idea what he's going to be this hard.
Oh yeah.
I mean you're,
you're working hard in elevation with weight on your back all the time.
And for me,
like my side,
I'm not a real big guy but I can carry a lot of weight for a long ways.
I mean I would say body,
it'd be kind of fun to do like a comparison.
Bodyweight to bodyweight,
carry something up the mountain because I,
that's what I do all the time.
I carry animals out for my job is to pretty much a human meal carry shit.
You must develop like really great course to ability to,
because it's all about balancing that heavyweight on your back and then walking
with it and you,
you,
you have to stay tight.
Like every,
you can't slow
just getting,
getting used to the weight and like,
like you say,
you're used to that kind of pressure and pain and you realize my have get
through it.
Human beings are very adaptable.
It's a matter of like going on and on and on.
Like I have friends that don't work out and one of the most hilarious things
over,
I was taking one of my friends who was a comedian who doesn't work out to the
gym and try and put them through a workout,
like a just a fairly easy workout and watching them just turn blue and gray and
looked like he was dying and heaving and coughing and hang onto the,
did the recovery time he needed in between sets was hilarious.
It's like you realize like this guy just,
here's what this is what a body looks like when it's never been pushed and have
allowed it to live for 35 years on booze and and shitty food and then you take
them to the gym.
I want to get in shape.
Cool.
Come on,
I'll bring it to the gym.
I'll just put you,
don't kill me.
I'll put you through just a normal marginal workouts.
Yeah,
nothing crazy.
No hill sprints,
you know.
No clean and jerks,
no dead lifts,
nothing nutty.
I just want to get you doing some pushups.
Bear crawls a couple of Chin ups and just see the body reacting.
But if he had just done it like there's nothing exceptional about a person's
body,
you can do pushups and Chin ups.
It's normal.
It's normal stuff.
You just have to do it.
But if you did it,
just do one.
Do one set a day.
Well,
how many can you do?
Can you do five?
Okay,
do five today.
Tomorrow,
try to do five again and let's do this for a week.
Just do that for a week and then at the end of the week,
let's work it up to six.
Let's get crazy.
He's tried to do six today and if you just do that for six months,
guess what?
You can do 20 Gen apps.
It doesn't seem like it works that way,
but it really does.
You just got to put in the numbers.
And with a guy like you,
you're putting in the numbers for your hunting.
You know you're always did.
It's a part of your normal life.
Like every time I go hiking with Rinella,
I just,
I laughed that fucking mountain goat.
I can't keep up with them.
And you know,
he's just doing it every day.
He doesn't get tired like you'll be heaving and Helvin I'm going to how good a
shape you think you are.
The only thing that gets you prepared for doing that is doing that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's exactly it because I've,
I've taken out and hunted with a few professional athletes.
These guys are human specimens of the highest degree like they physically and
then they try hiking with me.
Absolutely.
They just don't get that does like,
no,
no.
I trained for this is what I do.
He'll fit or whatever.
Right.
If you put me in,
if I'm going to go bench press like humans president,
this is not going to happen but put a heavy pack on my back and I'll just hike
forever.
That's a good way of putting it.
He'll fit your fit for what you do.
What do you,
what do you use for like a pack?
What is your equipment when you like when you pack out,
meet,
what kind of pack do you use?
A either an internal frame or external frame.
What company do I just started using a kfar pack.
It's pretty good.
It's,
I actually used one a long time ago when they first started.
He'd say Kfar Faru I a f
a R.
U.
K.
Farro.
Keep,
it looks like key for real.
Uh,
it's got like a little rhino
symbol and either use that or for an external frame.
I've been using the outdoorsman.
One wilderness.
Yeah.
Outdoorsman outdoorsman was.com.
That's what Rinella uses.
Yeah.
So they've designed these packs primarily for guys like you that are going to do
what you did in Alaska.
Yep.
Where are you going to walk?
Hours and hours and hours with giant slabs of meat on your back.
Yeah.
And that's,
yeah.
Special gear for a special task because it puts the weight on your,
on your hips and your sink,
I guess.
Yes.
Right.
The right above your tailbone there,
because you don't want the weight,
you know,
you want it above your hips so you've got full mobility and can move,
but kind of distribute the weight through the frame to your,
to your hips and yeah,
you can put some serious weight and some of these packs and go.
I mean,
no joke.
I've,
I've packed out a whole elk myself in one trip before
one trip.
Yeah.
Instagram of this one.
This dude,
we took every piece of meat,
ribs,
uh,
everything like boned out and I've got a pack loaded with me and then I'm like
dragging two quarter up this little hill.
It was pretty cool.
And the guy's looking at me gone,
Huh?
Yeah,
I didn't think you were much when I showed up,
but I,
you're doing it.
I'm good on Ya.
So that's if you're,
you know,
you only got to go a short distance.
It was like a mile and a half.
So he just said,
fuck it.
Let's just do it all one job.
Go back when he was two miles,
it was uphill for,
I would say half a mile,
something like that.
And then the rest was downhill.
So I figured,
well shit,
I just get home.
And when you did that Alaska trip,
like how long did it take you to recover?
There's,
you drag it onto there.
That's a whole elk basically.
Basically.
Yeah.
I might've when I took that picture,
I might've had some of it out at the top already.
I can't remember.
Yeah,
that's a lot of fucking weight.
Like how long does it take you to recover from that,
that a Alaska trip?
Uh,
I mean I recover pretty quick as the,
during the days.
I mean,
when I sit down and recover,
I guess afterwards,
me and my brother gorged like two bears on a fresh jail.
We got back to Kodiak and we ate at this pizza place.
It was probably the best meal I've ever eaten in my life.
I don't know.
There's just so hungry.
You're like,
yeah,
we just fucked.
Yeah,
we just went and got his ma or as many calories as we could.
We just were under or just gorge.
Just ate and ate and ate and ate and ate and then just slept the whole next day.
So I'd say a day of solid recovery.
God,
that's so crazy.
That's such a wild experience that that Kodiak island man was the subject of
that television show that was really controversial because it had James Hetfield
from Metallica was the the narrator.
Do you know that that show some bear hunting thing?
Yeah,
it was a great wells filled with fucking
great I,
that's what I heard.
That just bear sounds in the bushes and the camera's shaking.
Yeah,
same bear sound and every commercial break.
What did you see him?
Where is he?
Then it would cut to commercial and then it's some stage
eg bear like from Cabela's big game hunter video game
there was,
it was so bad.
It was like there was one scene where these guys were stalking this bear and the
guy was about to pull the trigger on,
on his bow and then they cut to commercial and then they come back and then all
of a sudden the guy doesn't have a jacket on and his pack's not there and it's
like he's in the same scene.
But did he take his pack off where you reenacting this?
Did you forget to wear a jacket?
There was a lot of fuckery,
man.
There was,
and then I talked to this dude work on the set and he was explaining to me how
much fuckery was going on and then it made even more sense.
That's what I'm talking about,
the creating drama and I hate that,
but yep.
I,
there's,
I was watching some other Alaska show and there's supposedly about like a wolf
is coming to eat our cows and we're going to go kill this wolf and then there's
the wolf and then the guy gets off the horse and shoots the wolf and being a
hunter,
I mean you can immediately spot bullshit like instantly and he throws the wolf
on it.
It was this wolf that had been shot days ago.
I mean the thing had rigor mortis.
It's eyes are sunken and it looked like I just pulled it out of the freezer.
Oh,
me and my brother were laughing so hard.
He's like supposedly tying it on the
horse and he's just like a stove or oh God,
this is stupid.
They're pretending.
They just shot it.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's funny.
There was one episode of the Alaska,
the last frontier a that I watched where they were fishing and it was like this
really badly acted thing where they're like the bear,
there's a bear.
I hear a bear like stop freaking out.
We gotta get out of here and like the bears coming.
There he is.
Look,
he's right over there and you look over.
The bear is eating a filleted salmon.
Like they filleted the,
the the meat off the salmon and let it looks like clearly cut.
Like you can't get any slice.
Like it was totally from the store.
They laid this fucking filleted salmon out the bones in the head and everything.
They laid it out there for the bear to eat so the bear would like get close to,
they could film it and then they're pretending it's coming after them like,
fuck,
are you doing,
I can't watch your show now.
Now you got me.
I can't watch it.
Yeah.
That's one of the thing that's really cool about your show and Rinella operates
the same way as does Jim Shockey that uncharted show that he has.
Amazing.
That's an amazing show.
It's more like it's a more like of a cultural exploration shell than it even is
a hunting show.
I mean,
he goes to these places and eventually shoots an animal,
but he's in like the weirdest spots on earth,
really dangerous war torn areas and he's bow hunting a fucking goat or
something.
That's where it comes into the adventure aspect of it as well because there's so
many aspects to hunting.
The benefit is the meat,
but while you're getting your meat,
you get these rich experiences that you can't get any other way.
Well,
you get a deeper understanding of life itself in,
in,
in the sense of the actual biological life on earth.
You get a deeper understanding of not just experiencing it from a video or
reading an article about it,
but from actually being there in the environment where these things live,
you get it.
The other thing is you get to be a part of nature,
not just a watcher of nature,
not just a bystander like even doing the apex predators show.
I'm looking at the way an animal lives and then trying to see how humans compare
and then go do it.
And that doing it part is completely different than the watching your part.
I can watch the great blue heron do something and there's it.
The heroin episode is obviously,
there's some things that are ridiculous about it.
Like I decided to go into a river wearing stilts.
I know that this seems like you're trying to make entertaining television,
but,
and at first I thought is this is going to be one of those things where it's
like the filleted Sam and type show.
Now that's a little bit last thing I want.
So I look at the way the great blue heron haunts and I'm,
you know,
birdwatching for majority of first part like watching the way these animals do
something.
And by watching my thought I understood it and then I went and did it in a
similar fashion where I'm now putting myself in the experience of dealing with
things like water,
refraction,
deep water clarity,
uh,
trying to sneak in and,
and,
and be on this elevated platform and the experience of doing it.
I learned something about that bird that I would have never learned otherwise.
And it was like this light on moment where I thought,
okay,
even in these,
in the midst of these semi ridiculous things,
I'm learning something that I can't learn by observing.
I have to learn by doing.
Now were you using a bow or a spear?
Spear.
Spear and light refraction.
From what I understand it with bow hunting,
you have to shoot in the water like maybe six inches below where you think the
fishes.
Yeah.
So it,
it depends.
It varies on water clarity,
angle of the sun,
depth of the fish.
And there was some,
some point I realized the fish were so deep that the spear wouldn't even really
reach them with enough force for penetration.
So was that like how,
how much penetration for deep,
deep.
So it's like three feet,
so three feet.
So by the time the spear,
if you throw the spear,
by the time it gets down to the fish,
they just
ghost.
Yeah,
they see a common.
So yeah.
Hmm.
Did you get any of that?
Oh,
don't tell me.
J eight.
Spoiler alert.
Yes.
Don't do it yet.
You know where you can find that Apex Predator.
Yes.
That's what I hear.
I hear an apex predator.tv channel.
You can buy the season for 1499 you can't go out or a sportsmans channel every
Thursday eight my DVR has four of the coyote episodes on it for some reason.
Oh,
something went wacky cause it's got all kinds of,
Harrington is,
I think it's like a couple of times on Thursday cause it's eight eastern and
Pacific.
Which I wasn't smart enough to figure that out.
Somebody had to tell him what that meant.
Like,
oh no,
no.
If plays it eight,
eight,
yeah.
Eight over here.
Eight over there.
So,
um,
how am I,
how many of these things have you done?
Six episodes.
Do you think you're going to continue to do more?
Yeah,
I hope so.
Do you really get to determine that is people's involvement in viewing and
viewership and other things,
which I think it's a,
this is a show that I've seen a lot of shows and this is a show that I want to
watch and that's,
I wanted to make a show that I wanted to watch.
And so this is what we attempted to do here is making sure that I want to watch.
So it's got one viewer,
me and if other people their works to be like,
that's not enough.
Okay.
You like it.
But you know Billy Bob over here has to like it as well.
No,
I enjoyed it.
I mean I've only seen the one the coyote with the buffalo episode,
but I really enjoyed it.
I think it's a really well done show.
Like all the 0.0 shows their grades.
They do Anthony Bourdain's show,
they do the meat eater show.
It's just,
it's a great company.
They just know how to do it.
They do it right in production and they,
you know,
they can take a concept that seems out there and it's just one of those shows
you,
you have to watch it to understand it.
I mean,
I could talk about it,
but if you really want to see if you like it or not,
you have to watch it.
I think guys like you are really important in the world of hunting because
you're this,
you're what you represent is what doesn't fit.
When these guys have this stereotypical idea of what a hunter is,
the stereotypical idea of what a hunter is to a person doesn't know any hunters.
They want to think of them as these loud mouth,
drunken dummies.
You don't really care these Babak type characters and Rinella flies in the face
of that as does Jim Shockey as do you.
I think it's,
it's really important that people don't throw out the baby with the bath water
because this the,
yeah,
those people are repulsive.
Yeah.
The people who mean the the assholes that like laugh and mock these animals as
they're shooting them and people who are drunks are going out there and and
irresponsible use of firearms and weapons.
He right.
I agree with you as,
as anybody that's listening,
someone who disperse disrespects the lives that they're taking,
you know,
and and,
and does it in this really repulsive way there I am a agree.
I,
I'm with you if you're an anti hunter because of those people.
I would probably,
if they were all like that,
I would be like that too.
But that's not what hunting has been,
has it as it's been explained to me and as I experienced from guys like Ryan
Callahan,
from guys like you,
from all the people out there that I've run into that are real hunters have been
very respectful,
very fascinated by it,
intrigued,
constantly curious as to the nature of these animals and super respectful of the
lives of these animals that they take.
You know,
I think too,
it's because for a long time people,
I think there's a lot of hunters,
they have very similar views to myself.
And for a long time they just haven't had necessarily the ability or the pulpit
to show that there's other people out there like that.
Because when I first started,
I've always wanted to get into hunting television.
And when I first started trying to break into it,
uh,
I got a criticism that I w there,
cause there was this model,
it was that bubba hunter guy and I wasn't that guy,
you know,
and so that the person that told me,
well if you really want to do this then you need to do whatever.
And I was on a hunt and I shot a deer and it was like I was told that I need to
celebrate and some extravagant fist pumping type way.
And I,
I did it for that moment and I immediately regretted,
I felt horrible.
I felt like this isn't me and if this is what it is,
I don't want to do this.
And I got,
it was like,
and that right there told me like if this is that industry and this is that I
don't want to be a part of this,
but,
and then my thought was,
you know,
there's probably other people out there like me that if they had the chance to
do it,
how just be myself and do it,
then they would recognize that and maybe change the whole the whole way things
are going.
And that's my goal.
I mean,
it'd be awesome to be a part of the people that change the way people see
hunters because I think there is the ability to make that change because there
is a lot of us out there that respect nature,
respect the animals,
see it as a way of life and not just as some crazy bubba guy out there hooting
and hollering and fist pumping and doing his thing and not respecting what we
have.
The lack of appreciation for the life that you're just taken.
And also the lack of understanding of the complexities of the whole situation is
also,
uh,
one of the disturbing things about the whole quote on quote bubba thing.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
the,
the show that you put on,
like we got a good and we got a good,
and jihad like faking it,
faking it because
there's,
don't get me wrong,
there's nothing wrong being excited,
right?
Because,
and it's a different kind of excitement.
It's an excitement where you're excited for high.
It's hard to explain the type of excitement because it,
it's,
uh,
I took an animal,
but I'm excited because of the challenge and what it represents to me.
Like it,
it went through this,
it's not always a solemn moment,
but it's an excitement in this very deep moment where you did take a life of an
animal and you need to respect that.
And for me,
I always have,
and I've expected the entire journey to get to that point.
And so for me to smile behind an animal to me means it's not disrespectful.
Right.
There's nothing wrong with being with a big animal that you shot the very happy
it all worked out well and smiling.
Correct.
But people do.
They think,
Oh,
you've got to be somber.
You've just killed.
You've just taken a life.
Well,
why?
If you respect the life,
if you're happy that it all worked out well,
you're,
you're happy with your accomplishment and your hard work paid off.
Why can't you smile?
Is it disrespectful to the life that you've taken to smile?
It doesn't make the life any less significant if you don't smile or do smile.
It doesn't change anything.
But what I think what you bring to the table and what you know,
guys like Shockey or Rinella bring to the table is a level of,
of
intellectual capability,
uh,
level of,
the ability to communicate really complex situations to the average person that
doesn't ever get involved with taking the life of an animal to fruit to
communicate that in a way where someone could be listening to this podcast.
And it's one of the things that I get from people that listen to the podcasts
that have hunters on the go.
I never had this opinion of hunting until I listened to these guys in these
podcasts.
I always had this really negative,
really stereotypical view of what a hunter is and now I kind of understand it.
And um,
I've gotten that like guys on my message board,
there's guys on my message board that have evolved over the time.
They've been there where they were there years ago and they had this idea like
all hunters are assholes.
And then as time went on,
they kind of been exposed to all these different people and all these different
conversations.
They realize,
oh,
we're,
we're just involved in this weird culture that has this,
this compartmentalization of various aspects of life.
And the big one is where you get your food from.
So there's people that are criticizing people that do it themselves.
There's no better way for an animal to die than by a hunter.
There really is no better way.
If you shoot a deer or an elk and that animal is dead within seconds,
that is the most peaceful way it's ever going to die,
the most pure way you're ever going to acquire me.
It's so much less struggle and less less suffering.
Then being a domesticated animal that's raised to be slaughtered,
it's so much better than killed by a Predator out in the wild.
It's going to slowly eat you asshole first.
You know?
I mean there's,
there's no better way.
If you really truly love animals,
you've got to take into account a few undeniable truths.
One is that populations need to be controlled and they are controlled through
the natural way with predators,
but when we live in those environments,
you have to pick a team.
If you're going to say team people,
well then you're going to have to control the predators as well and you have to
control the game animals because look tried living in upstate New York where you
can't even drive down the road without slamming into a suicidal deer.
I mean they have some places where they have to control the populations of deer
so badly that they have,
like in Pennsylvania they don't even have a season.
This is parts of Pennsylvania where you could just go and just shoot deer all
the time and he's like suburban areas.
They did an episode of bone collector on it cause these guys got up in a tree
stand in the summer and just fucking shooting deer and left and right.
They're everywhere because they're the people who are running into them.
They're getting deer ticks.
People are getting,
well Lyme disease because of it.
There's,
there's a lot more to what hunting is and to what,
what it represents to the people that are involved in it.
Then the bubba image.
Yeah.
And there's always,
the thing that always makes me laugh is the people that say,
oh we'll just release more predators to control.
Like if you're all about animal population control,
like make it before humans.
Like before Hume,
they are the,
what did they say?
It was fine before we got here.
And I always laugh to say when is when we got here,
you mean white people is a waspy out look on life.
Like before we got here,
before people came across the land bridge,
like humans and animals have been,
especially on an art con on any continent have been coexisting for a very long
time and humans have been a prime hunter of these animals as a,
as a Predator in the natural food chain.
I mean the animals that we didn't hunt no longer exists.
I haven't seen a t rex in a long time.
So we were in a route for them.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's the argument to,
you know,
if you want to really bring it back to the old days,
let's start bringing dinosaurs.
Exactly how.
Yeah.
Well one of the main arguments with how human beings brains developed as to
large sizes because of hunting,
because it's a sophisticated methods that we need to employ to make sure that we
kept eating food,
mood
and,
and one of the things that like looking at apex spreader really kind of looks at
humans and animals.
And,
and what we,
how we've adapted and learned from nature if you,
if we were out there and,
okay,
well yeah,
our brains,
it all comes back to we have every animal out there couldn't possibly beat us in
certain way or whatever has specialized in certain way,
but it comes back to our brains.
We can figure out how to do what they do best.
And that's what the show explores,
how we figure out how to do what they do best and see how we compare to it.
And a lot of times we may not compare and in a certain way,
but it comes back to using our brains and figuring out a way to make up for
adaptations.
So you did eight episodes this year,
you did the coyote,
the wolf alligator.
What are the golden mean?
Oh,
six Golden Eagle.
Yeah.
So is the coyote one was looking at that Kaplan painting,
but using the coyote skin in that fashion.
So the coyote,
the wolf,
the Golden Eagle,
the great blue heron,
the river otter,
and the American alligator.
And if you,
when you're done with all this,
what are your next ideas?
Ah,
we've got,
I want to do,
so even it's called Apex Predator,
but sometimes titles of shows,
maybe Celine,
because I want to also want to look at every aspect of nature,
not just predators,
because I think there's a lot of other animals that can teach us things.
So we're,
we're considering humans as an apex Predator.
How did we get to this point by learning from nature as well as these changes
that we've made.
So one thing that I would like to do is look at camels and the way they carry
water,
because humans are,
I at Campbell can carry water and humans are one of the only predators that can
carry water.
So you think of that as an advantage.
And Hannah,
how we compare to a camel,
like how much water can camera,
how long they can go stages of dehydration.
So I'd like to explore that and hunt in a desert situation for an animal that,
that necessarily not,
I wouldn't be hunting for camels and quote,
trust me,
I,
that's not something I want to get into.
But uh,
uh,
another desert animal,
maybe an AOD at or something.
And in a very arid climate.
Uh,
what else there was,
um,
I'd really like to look at the way mountain lions there.
They're so quiet when they walk and some of these,
you look at some of these episodes,
you just see it as a 30 minute episodes.
Some of these episodes I've trained for months to prepare to do this episode.
Uh,
the wolf episode,
I mean I was training,
running,
doing a lot of things to prepare myself to be able to attempt to run an elk
down.
And one of these episodes that we had slated an idea of,
I was training for is this mountain lion episode where I compare how mountain
lions,
like the amount of noise they make when they walk is very little.
I've had them just walk past me,
never heard a thing.
So let's measure it,
kind of measure how loud it mountain lion is when it's walking and then us with
our boots on and us with our bare feet and then so and then go and do a hunt
barefoot.
And so for months I was training to harden my feet and get 'em tough enough
where I could go in the desert and hunt an animal barefoot,
but we ended up not doing that episode.
So for months I was walking around there but just I think because this is how
crazy your a toughening my feet so I'm going to have to do that all over again.
But there's a that that's one of them and we've got a lot.
You got any crazy ideas because there's a lot of,
a lot of cool animals out there that I'd like to explore.
We have,
did you get your feet?
I could walk for a while and,
and not worry about it but so they just got thickly calloused and yeah,
they're already,
I think what I've noticed is it was more of a a sensory thing.
Your feet don't necessarily get that much tougher.
You just learn to feel the ground different.
Will you ever seen that from dual survivor
that walks everywhere barefoot?
Yeah.
He's such a goofball.
It's like one of those shows where you know these guys like for sure there's
some fucker going on in the show for sure.
Yeah.
But this guy it,
whereas no shoes like this,
this,
this idea that you know,
to really truly survive,
you know,
you get,
you're going to have to go without shoes because occasionally you find yourself
with no shoes and then you'd be fucked because your feet are soft.
So he doesn't want to be in that situation.
So it's fetus,
they're always hard.
It does tough.
And your feet.
I did before I did,
I did like a lot of research,
just some,
there's some crazies out there that are all about this like new shoe thing and
there's dudes that talk about drawing like a fake sandal on your foot.
So cause you can't go into place as you know,
like no shoes,
no shirt,
no service.
So they've got all these like tricks of making like a rope,
a pair of cord fake Sandal so people don't really notice that you're barefoot
was and then how to like get into it and start by going on varying terrain and
actually had to spend,
while I was trying to toughen my feet,
I had to spend some time in la.
So I was like cruising down downtown la and your skid row barefoot.
And I thought this is a good way to pick up a disease.
I'm not saying
exactly like glass and all kinds of stuff.
That's probably the biggest training near skid row when the cops pull you over
weed,
I'm training for a hunting show.
Fuck.
Exactly.
That's all you're going to jail is.
So there's,
we've got a lot of,
a lot of things.
Slate,
a lot of different animals.
I want to look at a trapdoor spider.
They're cool to me.
Trapdoor,
spiders or spider,
what are they?
It's a spider that hides and then when something comes by,
jumps out real fast and grabs it.
So I wanted to build some kind of hobble and weight in it and tried to grab it,
a deer or something.
And it comes from,
so we've got all kinds of fun stuff like that.
Um,
when you grab the deer or will you try and kind of try to kill it like with a
knife or something?
And I think,
uh,
on those type of episodes I probably let it go because I have the opportunity to
let it go.
And,
and I may,
I,
I don't really know.
I think I would just let it go.
How much do you communicate with people that are critics of hunting?
Uh,
I don't communicate with very many people ever because I'm always out doing
stuff.
But you mean like in my day to day?
Do you ever have issues with people that have problems with hunting?
And I don't,
that's one of the things about hunting that I think is
kind of weird is there's,
there's not a lot of communication.
There's like the converted,
like preaching to the choir.
And then there's these other people that have these misconstrued ideas is
misconceptions about what hunting is.
And they don't seem,
one of the problems,
they don't seem to get together and talk that often and I've seen Rinella have
conversations with people that were kind of anti hunters I guess.
You know,
actually in my day to day I do have a lot of conversation with people that
aren't hunters,
but there they're also people that are close to me and they know it.
Yeah.
I'm like family members that are hunters.
You,
it's funny as my
brother's girlfriend comes from a family that not hunters,
like she's the typical Yogi type that would never consider hunting.
She didn't even like eating very much.
Meat gave me and now this year she went and got her a hundred safety and is
going to go hunt elk.
Whoa.
Because I think when you really sit down and think about it,
if you're talking to somebody that like myself or you know people that are like
minded to me,
there's a lot of things that we can pull from that.
If you just actually had a real conversation and take out all the bullshit of
the,
I don't even know on both sides.
I call it like the hunting propaganda and the non hunter propaganda,
the things that you're told and you think or whatever.
You just actually have a real conversation about it.
It makes sense.
I'm saying makes sense.
It makes sense and it's also,
it sounds bizarre and contradictory,
but it's very spiritual.
Yeah.
There's something.
It sounds cool.
I go,
no,
it's,
you're taken alive.
I get all the arguments.
I understand the arguments,
but I'm telling you there's something,
there's something even psychedelic about going into their world and and hunting
them,
dipping your toe into the wild,
the true wild.
There's something like boundary dissolving about that it,
it changes the way I looked at the whole world.
It really did.
Like the first time I went deer hunting,
the,
one of the crazy things about it was looking at this dear look,
locking eyes with this thing in the wild and understanding the roles that we
have.
My role is the Predator that his role is trying to get the fuck away from me and
then taking his life and killing and eating it.
And I was like,
this is a spiritual experience,
a deeply spiritual experience in a weird way that I didn't anticipate.
I anticipated it being maybe somber and that I would have to get over the
sadness of it all and then I might not even want to do it again and maybe I just
become vegetarian.
Those were real considerations that I had,
but after the event,
I felt like there's,
there's something that most folks are missing about this experience and I think
it's because it's been very poorly represented in our culture by media,
by these,
the,
the stereotypical bubba type by all these different,
the different pieces of information that have sort of filtered down to the,
the average urban civilization inhabitant,
the,
we don't,
we don't have a connection to it.
So we're basing our opinions on it.
It's just based on stereotypes on,
on these immediate depictions of what a hunter is.
Yeah,
it's,
it's those kind of false ideas.
But then when you,
if you actually got to talk to someone,
but it's also one of the things,
you talk about it.
We talk about,
we're sitting here talking about it,
but until you go through that experience,
you necessarily don't know what it feels like,
what it means,
what it means to you.
My mom's Stepdad called GRANDPA.
He loves fishing big out,
like loves nature,
hiking.
Other things went hunting,
shot a bird,
felt really sad,
never went hunting,
but that was his experience.
So everybody has a d maybe experiences it in a different way,
but you really don't know until you jump in and do that experience.
I talked to someone who had that similar experience with a deer.
They've shot a deer and the deer was moaning when it was on the ground,
like all this crazy noises and never went hunting again.
Right.
Yeah,
and it just depends on maybe your,
your experience,
but also I think it depends on how your reason for going out there.
Like if you are,
I've never hunted before,
and you say to yourself,
I would like to go hunting because I'd like to eat less meat that I don't know
where it came from.
Be more involved in that process.
Like if you went out and said,
I have a goal that maybe one day I'd like to in my house only eat things that
I've killed even before you've even killed anything.
You go out with that mind set up and then it becomes a utility thing.
It becomes like a part of your process for your life and I think it affects you
differently because you go,
okay,
there's a reason for this.
There's a like,
I'm eating animals anyways,
I'm killing animals anyways.
I might as well be a part of the process.
You're killing them with your credit card,
your money,
somebody else.
Maybe you're not seeing it,
but it's happening.
It's not going to not happen.
Okay.
That's something that has a direct result of your choices.
That's something that we conveniently try to distance ourselves from.
Yeah.
So if you can be part of that process,
then it's not something,
I mean it's,
it's a,
it's a different experience.
It really is.
I don't,
it's very hard to explain,
but I think we,
we sit here for however long and try to explain it.
It would take days.
Yeah.
You just,
it's very hard for people to get involved too that aren't hunters grates me and
I don't know what,
because I get a lot of,
a lot of people,
uh,
on social media or whatever that I've listened to,
like found me through your podcasts or whatever.
And a lot of them have now jumped into hunting and there's still a lot of them.
They're trying to figure out how to do it.
And I would say the main question I get asked is,
is how I get into,
or how,
how would someone get into it?
Really?
I mean,
the first thing you got to take the hunter safety and do the legal requirements
because once you have that,
then your barriers to entry are slowly getting less and less.
And then really just getting hooked up with somebody that hunts.
And maybe that's through like hunting conservation organizations.
I think there's a big niche there that could step up and go to the,
some of these events because I find there's a lot of conservation organizations
that you can join,
say wild sheep foundation or elk foundation and you'd go out on these projects
and do something for a while.
I've like build a water guzzler,
receipt,
an area that's burnt,
do all these things are conservation efforts that are done by hunters and you
meet other people because hunters if you,
if you meet him in the flesh are probably really willing to help you out if you
were like,
I really want to get into this and you've got to find the right type of guy too
or woman or whatever to to get you into it.
But that's the easiest way is to have somebody show you like a mentor.
This a place where I hunted Moose,
I should tell people about this guy cause he's awesome.
Big country outfitters.
Dot.
Ca uh,
in uh,
northern BC.
Um,
my cockroach is a guy who is a,
the,
the main guide.
He's got other gods there as well that work with them.
But,
uh,
he does that with people that have never hunted before.
He'll take you through the whole deal,
take you through the whole explaining to you how to shoot,
explaining to you how you know how to breathe when you're pulling the trigger.
How do you know what shot placement aiming,
you know,
how to do the whole deal.
He'll take you through the whole day,
stalking,
hunting,
butchering the whole deal.
And um,
he's,
he's about as real a guy as you can get to.
I,
I love that dude.
He's fucking awesome.
I had a great time with him and,
uh,
he's one of the few outfitters that I know that welcomes people that have never
had an any hunting experience whatsoever.
And he had some disaster stories because of that.
People panic and they freak out.
And
those are my favorite people to guide though because they don't come in with an
expectation of something that there's,
you know,
I mean,
there are hunters out there,
they have just expectations that I'm not okay with.
And so people that are looking for a new experience,
they're there for the experience.
Like people that go in with an expectation of a certain size animal.
Yeah.
Or like,
you know,
I think the,
or,
yeah.
Like they,
they pay for a hundred.
I don't sell animals.
I'm,
I'm an outfitter.
I sell and a hunting experience.
I take you hunting.
I don't sell you an animal.
It doesn't just cause you go hunting doesn't mean you're going to kill
something.
Yeah.
It's not possible.
No,
it's not.
No one can be there for a tea.
Like if you're new and you're there for the experience,
you're learning something.
Whether you kill someone,
you're not.
Obviously you want to shoot something that's the end goal,
that's the result.
But it's so much more than that.
It is.
It is so much more than that.
And I hope these conversations do help.
I think they do.
I think that people learn from them.
And I think that where we're doing our part to it express what we've learned
with,
for you,
it's your whole life.
For me,
it's just over the last few years.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's not what people think it is.
And if you're tired of these conversations to go fuck yourself,
I'm tired of you not knowing their,
yeah.
Apex Predator.
Dot.
TV Apex Predators on Sportsmans Channel Thursday night at eight o'clock on both
coasts.
Remy Warren on Twitter,
r e m I Instagram and Instagram at [inaudible].
You're,
you're awesome,
dude,
man.
Really appreciate you having me on.
It's been fun.
This is awesome.
Anytime.
And we got to hunt one day.
Go elk hunting in Montana with some bows.
Let's do it.
We'll send it over.
Okay.
We'll set it up right now.
We're going to set it up.
All Fair.
All right.
Love you guys.
Oh,
I'll be back tonight at eight o'clock.
Aubrey de Grey,
uh,
anti aging specialist.
Uh,
a real scientist just should be fun.
All right,
see you soon.
Bye.